look oh
is
i'm going to call a meeting to order on
can i get everybody standing in pledge
to the flag of the united states of
america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
and uh
representative dolan
represents pmit here
clerks here
a representative
here
representative mcbride
representative melvin
yeah
representative power here
representative
gilman
here
thank you
representative majority here
representative davis
representative
here
representative gallagher
okay uh representative
samson would like to start and introduce
thank you mr chairman and members of the
peter samsich rockingham 27 portsmouth
uh i thank you for the opportunity to
introduce hb
1374 to you
a bill relative to the membership of
local land use sports
this is a very simple bill
a short prehistory
uh back in 2020
playing board decision in portsmouth
decided to
green light a new construction building
which was appealed by several residents
of the of portsmouth
under the under the with the um
contention that
two members on that planning board
two exoficio members on that planning
board were in fact not residents of this
of the municipality
and as they saw the law written
all
members on municipal boards land use
boards are required to be members
or residents of that municipality
they appeal that ruling to the superior
court
and the superior court said well
it is true that
a regular members are required to be
residents of the municipality
but exoficio members are not
not explicitly mentioned in the rsa
and so therefore it is assumed that they
also can vote
even if they're not members even if
they're not residents of the
municipality
so what this bill does is it changes
that rsa to say
a municipality can establish such boards
but
voting members on that board must be
must be residents of the municipality
and this includes exophisio members as
well
so it explicitly mentions that so that
that corrects that error which most
people thought that these boards were
all
manned by people who were residents of
the municipality and it doesn't preclude
ex-official members who don't live in
the municipality from being on these
boards and advising these boards however
it prevents them from voting when it
comes to the voting rights the
municipal association contacted me and
said we should make an exception in this
bill and it has been made in a certain
section
to exclude building inspectors because
there are many smaller towns in new
hampshire
that
share a building inspector with another
town and that building inspector should
be part of that board when they make
decisions because that is integral to to
the
function of that that particular person
so that's what the bill is all about it
was requested by a resident of
portsmouth that i submit to spill on his
behalf
does anybody have any questions from his
representative
representative gallagher
so um
this bill is sounding kind of familiar
um i was checking my notes
and saw that previously there was
hb 392
this term which
did
something similar um could you explain
um
what happened with that one and like
why
and like compare and contrast this one
thank you
thank you representative callier for
that question uh the answer is pretty
simple uh this was submitted uh last
year but it died in the house it never
got a vote in the house and that's why
it's allowed to be brought back again
because it was there was no vote in the
house on the bill
thank you representative tripp
uh thank you chairman thank you for
taking my question
uh
how many members are there on a planning
board
i really can't answer that because i
think every municipality is a little
different as far as i know and it and
this is not just about one board it's
multiple
land use boards in various towns and
municipalities so i don't know exactly
what the if there's a fixed number or
not
all right well uh follow up go ahead
are
my understanding is most are appointed
yes and the ex-officio members are
there because of a a
function they fulfill with the
municipality and the municipality wants
them part of that board
but the other ones are all appointed and
the ex-officio members are
staff members or people on the municipal
municipal payroll perhaps but some of
them in in the case of portsmouth we
have people who live in newberry port
massachusetts who are ex-official
members who were ex-official members on
representative
yes thank you
and thank you for your
testimony it's my understanding uh that
where the planning boards are either
elected or appointed
this would not change that that the
communities that
require that a person
foreign
thank you representative
that's exactly correct what you're
saying
and in our town we don't we don't elect
them they are appointed but i can see
that in some municipalities they will or
we would be elected so that wouldn't
affect any any any other feature of of
this of the way people are elected to
these boards or appointed no
representative manjuputi nice to see you
can you hear me now
okay uh thank you representative for
presenting this bill so my question is
like you already stated it applies to
all different boards
correct so the statute changing or the
rsa change in the rsa
will only include
the extra fischer if they're not living
in that and if they have to be elected
then they won't qualify but if it is an
appointed
they can
be a contributing member
it could be any board right
thank you representative uh it's the the
we're talking about rsa title um
was it lx i5 which is like
64. planning and zoning boards so not
all boards but planning and zoning
boards yes
and uh uh you know the the only
difference is that we're saying
specifically
that
you have to be a resident of
municipality whether you're exophysio or
not
that's the only time you can vote with
the only exception being building
inspectors
representative powell
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question is
it true that ex-officio members
had previously served on these um said
boards
uh
representative lasalles
thank you for taking my question
um why would you
uh exclude building inspectors
i understand the function of the
building inspector as a
giving advice to the planning board
zoning board whatever
but
i
really question whether a building
inspector should
cast a vote if they if they're not
residents
i just i am interested in your reasoning
thank you and thank you representative
for that question um
i can't say i know
enough about building inspectors to
answer that
thoroughly but the municipal association
was quite
concerned that
building inspectors that are shared by
multiple municipalities
should have a say in those decisions
um
uh
i don't know exactly how that works and
why why it's so important uh most like
the towns i'm familiar with they have
their own building inspector and that
person does not have to be
on those land use sports it's dependent
on the municipality to appoint them
so uh i i think it's probably true for
other municipalities if they decide to
put this person on the board
and he's a building inspector then he
would be allowed to vote according to
this bill if if they don't put him on
the board he's not going to be voting
and of course i think it's very
important to remember that ex-official
members often have a lot of
institutional memory so that these land
use sports do want to hear from them and
often get advice from them
but that doesn't mean they have to be
voting members unless they
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question my
apologies but could you briefly restate
the case that you cited
when you began your testimony i i didn't
hear all of it
this was in 2020
and this was a planning board decision
in portsmouth
the local planning board made a decision
and there were
the decision was
included two votes by ex-officio members
uh that
decision was challenged by several
residents of portsmouth and went to the
superior court
the superior court said
while it does there the statute does
refer to
requirement of residency as members on
those boards it doesn't specifically
exclude ex-officio members which is a
different quasi-different kind of
membership they're they're members
because of other services or positions
they have and since
the the statute doesn't specifically
mention them
the the superior court said they should
be allowed to vote
and and this this bill basically
corrects that by saying uh unless they
are in fact uh municipal residents they
shouldn't be voting
uh and like i said the only exclusion
being building
are these microphones shutting off
automatically
uh
this whole thing with the uh uh
even even the the thing with the having
a building inspector being part of the
board is a little bit fuddling to me
if
if it's elected then obviously they
would be
members of the community if they're
then uh
there's a possibility they wouldn't be
members of the community
uh this is our question there's a i'm
i'm creating the context thank you
but thank you for uh prompting me
uh
why
would uh
why would a uh a town
or a city
appoint
a non-resident to a uh
thank you mr uh thank you representative
tripp
you got me there
i think
any municipality
having
boards that make decisions for that
municipality should have members that
are residents of that municipality makes
a lot of sense to me
unless
they have people involved who are just
there for advisory purposes which i can
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
another question uh
well that that's the thing that uh like
i said is confusing to me because you
can have advisory people
present at a meeting
without having them members of the board
the site the case you cited that
the portsmouth created their own problem
uh i know i i i i think this is a
problem that's statewide
because i think like the court said
uh the role of ex-officio members was
not specifically mentioned in the
statute
and i would not be surprised that this
is a problem yes portsmouth created but
they assumed this was proper and i am
assuming that there are other
municipalities that do the same thing
and no one has challenged that at all
before so i can't be
sure about it but that's what i suspect
thank you chairman and thank you
representative samsich
representative samsich am i correct
in reading this bill as saying
that all voting members of local land
use boards shall be residents so whether
the building inspector comes to the
meeting
if he or she is not a resident they
cannot be a voting member that's what
thank you representative and that
question
that's not quite correct uh you notice
that uh
it says pursuant to paragraph one two
and four
and five
and there's a there's a paragraph roman
number three
which is excluded that's the building
inspector part
so everything except the building
yes please could i have a follow-up
thank you
uh
so a building inspector can be appointed
to
a local land use board even if he lives
or she lives in the next town over
and can vote according to this
that's my understanding
you did shut off i have one question for
you um
most uh
towns will use uh ex-officials
especially for planning boards and
sony's
that i've known uh are
all appointed to begin with okay
um the ex-officios on those boards
uh do not have voting rights
and
so you're claiming that a building
inspector should have
building rights i mean voting rights on
those
thank you mr chairman for this question
my understanding from what the municipal
association shared with me is that when
we exclude them
from
this mandate that
that only residents are allowed to
to vote on these boards
i think that doesn't preclude
uh
the local municipality
allowing them to participate and maybe
even vote i don't know
specifically if they say so
right now however as the laws are as the
rsas are written
their role is pretty vague so that's i
think why probably some municipalities
don't let them vote and others let them
vote that's my suspicion
are there any other questions for this
thank you chairman and thank you
representative samsic so let's see if i
have this correct this time
am i correct in believing that your bill
says
that
all voting members of the board shall be
residents of the town except
in the case where the town appoints a
is that what it says yes
uh
there any other questions for this
witness
representative stavis sorry thank you mr
sharon thank you representative for
taking my question
so even if said building inspector
was duly appointed to said board
well first of all thank you for the
question
if the building inspector is a resident
of the town
or municipality yes they can vote
but that's different from what we just
heard i think well if if they're
appointed
to that land use board and they are
residents or even as ex-officio members
that doesn't preclude them from voting
the the title of ex-officio itself does
not preclude them from voting it's the
question of whether
they are residents of the municipality
and
uh
the only exclu the the
the only exception to not being a
resident is if you're a
a building inspector that is shared by a
town with other towns
where they can't be the resident of all
i see none i'm gonna close the hearing
on house bill 1374.
thank you very much
um
oh i didn't see that i'm sorry i can't
close the hearing
this is uh
natchez from
nhma
sorry about that i apologize no problem
mr chair i put that in about halfway
through because there were uh
some things that i just wanted to
clarify for the committee uh nate graves
for the new hampshire municipal
association
we do not have a position on this bill
i just want to clarify that this bill
modifies rsa 673 colon 1
which
designates
membership of land use boards it also
provides for some other land use
items such as the building inspector so
the building inspector is covered under
rsa 673-1 roman 3 and it and that
portion of the statute just says the
local legislative body
may provide for the
appointment of an inspector of all
buildings that doesn't provide that the
building inspector actually serves on a
board
the land use boards are other roman
numerals under that statute
essentially what this would
this bill would do is simply rewrite
the requirements there's already a
residency requirement that the
members of land use boards be
residents of the municipality and it
would it would just sort of shift where
that language comes into the statutes
i think there was a little bit of
confusion about what exofficio means so
i'm going to use an example here
so a planning board at a town
is comprised of five to seven members
plus one ex-official member who's either
a member of the select board or an
administrative official
appointed by the select board and that's
found under 673 colon two
um and that ex-officio serves as
um
essentially a representative of that of
the select board
of that other board um and has all the
rights and privileges of any other board
member
you know if it's a select board member
obviously there's a requirement the
select board be a resident of the town
if it's an administrative official that
may not necessarily be the case
but the building inspector generally
isn't going to serve on a land use board
simply because their role
isn't really to make decisions about
people's individual rights it's to go in
and say hey you know
your
whatever on your building isn't to code
it's it's too close you know the setback
is
is not far enough or whatever the case
may be
so we're really just talking about
um
the people making land use decisions for
residents of the town
i'm happy to take questions
are there any questions for
mr graves
i see none thank you very much thank you
anybody else would like to speak on this
bill
i'm going to close the hearing on 1374
and we will open the hearing on 1375 at
diane could you do me a favor i just
sent you
a text could you just introduce
in 1375 for me just introduce you and
thank you mr chair and thank you
colleagues
it's my privilege to introduce to you
house bill 1375 relative to the
definition of veterans
the prime sponsor um is unable to be
here at this time so i've been asked to
introduce the bill to the committee so
this bill
amends the definition of veteran
to include any any
servicemen discharged under honorable
conditions
and also amends the references to
honorable discharge to also align with
this definition
and in the framework of the bill as you
will see
it
it pertains to a couple of sections of
statute and most notably
as you can see throughout the the
amended language of the bill that it's
simple and straightforward and it
it makes explicit
a veteran discharged under honorable
conditions
referencing and pursuant to rsa 21 colon
which
delineates and specifies
at least
provisions for
a veteran to be
have been discharged under honorable
conditions
so and
this section of statute relates to the
veterans property tax credit thank you
thank you very much representative
i'm going to call now um
william
gandren
good morning member uh chairman members
of the committee my name is william
cadrell for the record
i'm the director for the new hampshire
division of veterans services i'm a
30-year veteran of the united states
navy and i'm a veteran or i'm a member
of manchester the community of
manchester i'm here to
read the testimony for
our support of this bill
the department of military affairs and
veteran services supports
hp 1375 is
is a resolution that seeks to amend the
definition of veteran to include any
discharge that is under honorable
conditions
and amend any references to honorable
discharge to align with this new
definition position
rsa 2150 defines a veteran as a person
who served the united states armed
forces for more than four years and
continues to serve
or has been discharged or released from
duty united states armed forces with an
honorable discharge or an
uncharacterized discharge
based on a service-connected injury
illness or disability
this definition excludes veterans who
served honorably but received general
discharges under honorable conditions
service members who receive general
honor honorable conditions are eligible
to receive federal benefits including
but not limited to va health care
va home loans va education benefits
insurance benefits
disability compensation and pension
benefits
the federal law establishes a bar to
benefits for veterans who are discharged
for a number of conditions including but
are not limited to
discharges or releases under
dishonorable conditions which is bad
conduct or dishonorable discharge
conscientious objectors who refuse to
perform military duties wear the uniform
or comply with the lawful orders of
conflict military authorities
the sentence of a general court martial
resignation resignation by an officer
for the good of the service desertion
discharge under honorable
other than honorable conditions issued
as a result of absent without leave for
a continuous continuous period of 180
days
this is the position of the department
that the state should make its myriad of
veterans benefits available to the new
hampshire veterans who by virtue of
their honorable service are eligible for
federal benefits as well
it is for these reasons the department
respectfully asks the committee to
favorably consider hb 1375 and for that
i'll take any questions thank you very
representative powell
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question unfortunately i
missed your name in the organization
that you're from could you please repeat
that thank you
my name is william goodroi
and i'm the director for the new
representatives davis
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
do you have any statistics on how many
uh
veterans under honor discharge under
honorable circumstances are in new
hampshire versus veterans who are
honorably discharged can what what is
the
what are the statistics there
thank you for your question um
unfortunately that number is not an easy
number to come to
um
veterans are not required to check in
with the division of veteran services
when they enter the state
um and there is really no way to track
in the system whether or not their what
their discharge is
um i have asked va for data
that may help
define that a little bit give us some
numbers because veterans who apply for
services that are general under
honorable
i could probably get a a list of all
those veterans from the va um but that's
only going to be veterans who actually
apply for benefits so if a veteran is in
the state of new hampshire and they
haven't applied for benefits their name
is not going to be on the list so they
wouldn't be counted so it's not a very
easy number to come to
follow would you follow up go ahead so
if it's not an easy number to come by
what could be the ramifications
of expanding the definition under this
bill
um
and how would
state officials in charge of
enforcing this bill
like i said
to get the exact number of general under
audibles is not going to be an easy
number to come by
but not all general honorables are going
to be eligible for all benefits in the
state of new hampshire for example
property tax credits
not everybody who's general under
honourable is going to own a home
so to determine how many of those are
going to want to get property tax credit
it'd be very difficult to ascertain uh
there definitely will be an impact on
the state
um because there are
obviously general under honorables that
are not receiving benefits now
there'll be more people more general
animals looking to get veterans plates
which as right now they're not eligible
for
there will be more general honorable
veterans who will now have the ability
to go to the veterans cemetery be buried
in the various cemetery which they
cannot be buried today more veterans
will have the ability to utilize the
veterans home
general under animals cannot so there
will be some impact
but i'd like to think the impact would
not be a negative impact
representative gallagher
oh um representative power already kind
of asked my question for me but um
since
i
i was still kind of unclear on
what could you spell your last name for
us as well just for note-taking purposes
yes
the last name is spelled g-a-u
d-r-e-a-u
okay representative cleve
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um
just for clarifications this just
changes our current statute here in new
hampshire to match the federal language
is that the only change that you see
happening thank you for the question is
that that is correct okay and may i have
a follow-up sir
go ahead thank you so much um the the
language on um
page one
that references it's around line 16
um
i think it's 15 and 16 that says um
that for the state who have served in
the armed forces of the united states
for not less than 90 days in times of
war
um
that would have been
for instance something to say like
vietnam veterans or something that may
be only served 90 days for whatever
their reason wasn't got got a discharge
is is that correct that is correct and
does not include um reservists that
possibly have served over 90 days
during their training when they're
active
that is correct okay thank you so much
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony bill
uh
i i got sort of a dumb question maybe
but can you tell me is this bill more
restrictive
or less restrictive as far as
a candidate being
a person going to looking for an
abatement
thank you for the thank you for the
question this will be less restrictive
as it stands right now if you separate
the military with a general under
honorable discharge you are not eligible
for state benefits
as a veteran you're not considered a
veteran in the state of new hampshire
so this bill would eliminate that and
because you're general under honorable
conditions your honorable conditions you
would then be
eligible for state benefits in the state
of new hampshire so it would definitely
be inclusive or additive a follow-up mr
chairman
so it's fair to say that those who are
already
already on the rolls if you're willing
for the abatement there
there's no change for them so but it
might add some
other veterans who don't qualify because
of the way the uh the description of
what a veteran
is is that correct thank you for the
clarification that is correct and we
don't know
what that number is it might yes i'm
sorry mr chairman a follow-up uh
we don't know whether there's in the
community whether there's two or ten
is it fair to say that that's not going
to be uh a large number
in each community
i don't imagine the number is going to
be too large but i do know that there
are definitely some people out there
that are affected by this currently
thank you mr thank you thank you mr
chairman
thank you for taking my question
how would this impact
homeless
veterans or veterans that don't like you
said the own not every veteran owns a
home
but they might be
eligible for some of the
other benefits that you
allude to
so how would that impact our veteran
population in our state
thank you for the question the only way
it's going to impact the homeless
veteran is if the homeless veteran is
generally under honorable if the veteran
is currently homeless and is honorably
separate separated they'd be available
eligible for all benefits that are for
the honorable veterans if they are a
veteran who is generally under honorably
separated and they are homeless they
would not be eligible for state benefits
that might assist them
based on the fact that they are
generally under honorable
one
yeah um
many especially i'm looking at the
health benefits
you know some homeless might
not be capable of applying for it
because of their state of mind or their
homeless and combination of it
and
how yeah how would how would you
establish the record of those veterans
if they are homeless they don't have the
documents that's a big issue with the
web va
am i correct
too
i i'm not i'm not sure how how to answer
the question i'm not really sure i
understand the question um
this this law this law is specifically
looking to bring in a group of veterans
into the veteran status that have not
been in the veterans status before
i'm not really sure how it affects what
you're speaking about
if i can clarify my question mr chair
excuse me if i can clarify my question
to
go ahead um in order to be qualified or
to be established as a veteran honorable
general right you have to have certain
documents and stuff if somebody is
homeless and i'm not able to
provide those
that would be an issue correct
that would be an issue but an issue not
not rectified through this legislation
my question has to do with
what is a
general discharge
under honorable and i i assume there are
general discharges under dishonorable
conditions
could you give me examples of why
somebody
would get a general discharge under
honorable conditions
but not get a honorable discharge
so general honor honorable thank you for
the question by the way general honor
honorable
is
a vehicle by which commanding officers
through the non-judicial punishment
system
can
have individuals separated from the
military and it's usually for con for
things that for the individual did not
meet standards so somebody who is for
example
not meeting weight standards um would
not has not committed a crime
they're not violating any laws
uh they would not get a bad conduct
nor dishonorable or other than honorable
discharge but they will be released
general under honorable conditions so
general discharge but they served
honorably
they just did not meet the standards for
thank you
um representative plea
thank you mr chairman and thank you
my my question is um
that
my aunt back in the day
um was she had to leave service because
she um became pregnant and back then you
got a general discharge
um i don't even believe they did
honorable or it was just a general
discharge in time since i think they've
changed it over i think she got changed
over to an honorable district so someone
such as herself would then qualify for
the benefits as long as she had time and
service that is correct thank you so
much
representatives
thank you mr chair and i don't know
to whom this question should be directed
um
but i'm wondering
given the potential impact this bill
might have why there is no financial
note
that's a good question i'll make note of
that
i can get back to you
thank you
i see none for this witness i would like
to call now
thank you
thank you mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen the committee
for the record my name is kevin grady
i'm a 25-year
veteran of our air force and i'm a
23-year veteran of the town of hooksett
lived here that long
today i'm here representing the state
veterans advisory committee and this is
my first chance to talk to you this
session so i thought what i would do is
take just about 30 seconds in tour to
tell you what it is we do and how we do
it we're actually chartered by state rsa
dash
a colon 8
with up to 20 member organizations which
we have right now and these are
organizations that would be familiar to
you like the veterans of foreign war the
american legion those folks
one of the things that we do we meet on
a monthly basis
and one of the things we do is we look
over the bills that are coming before
the legislature that have better impact
and we
vote and take a position and then we i
come and tell you what that position is
we support a wholeheartedly this
legislation um and for a couple of
reasons the first is that it
it kind of aligns things with what the
federal government's doing and i know
that that sometimes can be an unpopular
you know decision
around here politically but from the
military perspective whenever we can do
things like the the active military is
doing it it's better for us the national
guard for example there's a reason that
those folks go to active duty training
okay then there's not specific guard
training for to be a soldier or an
airman in our in our national guard they
go when they train alongside the active
duty folks because there's a chance that
at some point title 10 of u.s law is
going to kick in and they're going to be
called to active duty to help support
things our tanker folks over at pease
are doing this every single day so the
more we can sort of look like that the
better um the last thing i want to leave
you with is
i think a general discharge kind of gets
a bad rap
and as a former commander in the
military i can tell you as mr gadreau
did that
sometimes that's used for somebody who's
really doing a good job but just not
meeting the standards the weight
standard is an exceptionally good
example let me give you just a couple
more um
i wearing one of my other hats i'm an
air force academy admissions liaison
officer
and six years ago i put a young lady
into the air force academy and while she
was there in her junior year she
suffered a back injury
and she had to have that same surgery
tiger woods had you know where they fuse
your spine together and the department
of defense military evaluation review
board folks said hey we love you but
we're sorry you can't serve anymore so
she got a general discharge
from the military at that point now the
va
judging from the state from the national
level down the va is on the hook for
her medical stuff if that condition
deteriorates the va is on the hook to
pay for that for the rest of her life
but she doesn't qualify for anything at
the state level because it's a general
discharge okay and this is the person
who is so sharp if she wanted to be in
our state government she ought to have a
veteran preference to be in our state
government
the last thing i'll leave you with is
that
every year the services send people to
basic training that for whatever reason
it's just not a match made in heaven
we call this failure to adapt to
military service it's not their fault
necessarily they just picked a bad
situation and that person shouldn't
necessarily be penalized for the rest of
their life because that is a general
discharge as opposed to an honorable
discharge so
i'll conclude by just saying we do
support this legislation and um
available if anybody has any questions
thank you very much is there any
questions to this
representative tripp
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
uh
you kind of
got my peak my interest when you said
that uh if people were in boot camp and
they uh didn't quite fit in that they
would
get a uh general discharge is that
correct yes sir typically
uh follow up
one follow-up uh well in my preparation
for this hearing
i uh went
and looked to find out what kinds of
service discharges you can get
uh
and
the
there's obviously the honorable
discharge general other than honorable
why would
someone that failed to accommodate or
adapt to
the military get a
general discharge instead of an
entry-level discharge well it's it
out of basic training it might be that
but if they subsequently went to
follow-on training and washed out of
that and some of those trainings are up
to a year long then they then they
because they had served for longer the
the the service is not necessarily
characterized as um
it's characterized as honorable service
but not for long enough that people
would typically give someone an
honorable discharge and therefore they
probably would get the general
thank you mr kid thank you for taking my
question how would this impact a lot of
youngsters from high school
um
register or go
armed services right for training and
stuff
and if they are general discharge
they should be able to qualify for
educational through this bill
well
a lot of the educational benefits that
you're talking about representative are
are federal uh
okay federal level and and they would
still qualify for those um now if they
were if
if it was out of the national guard or
something like that and they were
discharging their general purposes and
they they probably wouldn't qualify for
the guard benefits either
okay follow-up one question yeah
so
the next one would be if somebody served
like you said
and didn't quite
uh meet the standards for the services
but they served for a year or two
so they will qualify for the medical
under these if they're general discharge
if they had a medical condition that was
part of the reason that they were
discharged yes they would
thank you
are there any other questions
representatives
sorry but thank you for
and thank you for taking my question
kind of a two-part question
general discharge under honorable
conditions does qualify for gi bill
benefits federally
i think those are excluded i'm sorry i
didn't hear your question um it wasn't a
question but here is my question can you
define for me
what it means
to serve
and i realize that's kind of an
open-ended question but in the examples
that you you gave about
failure to adapt to them to the
is that considered service
even if you go through the program and
the program's not for you
what how do you define service i i would
think that service is kind of in the eye
of the beholder
in that case it's it's it's pretty much
in the eye of somebody that you want to
to work for or whatever if you went and
tried to be in the military and you met
all of the entrance requirements to get
into the military and then you
you found out it wasn't for you at some
point on this profile and it might not
have been
it might not be might be partly way
through training it might be in their
follow-on training it might be in the
first year or two
of of service but i think that that
anybody that tries honorable or tries to
serve with good intentions to serve in
our military uh would deserve some
consideration as to
as to
their intentions and you know and and
and how they carried that out
very helpful thank you are there any
other questions to this witness
i see none thank you very much for your
testimony
and i'd like to call now i would like to
call miss
is that better uh good morning my name
is jim miesha i'm the chief assessor for
the town of hudson new hampshire and i
am here uh neutral on this bill um but
when i uh read these bills i ask myself
what could be the impact of these bills
uh i'm also a resident of town of
hooksett for 25 plus years
i researched online and there was a 2015
report from the office of the secretary
of defense that discharges from the
2014-2015 fiscal year
under honorable condition general and
honorable conditions
6.36 percent
of those discharges in that year that's
all i could find
so
um if if
we apply that to new hampshire
according to new hampshire department of
military affairs and veterans services
2019 is a document on town of hudson
website there are 9 99 249 veterans in
new hampshire
so
if you infer that 6.36 of them are under
honorable conditions
you could come up with 6 312 veterans
who are under that
but how many owned homes
according to the urban institute study
in 2017
78 percent of veteran households are
homeowners
that's the most recent i could find if
were homeowners that could mean there's
4923 more veterans
tax credits that might be able to be
granted assuming all eligible applied
and were otherwise eligible
according to the dra in 2020 out of all
the veterans tax credits that are given
there was about 54 654 credits
so
if if this were to pass
then more ventures would be getting tax
credits
it's unclear if rsa 72
dash a 4 comes in play or not
72 colon 27-a says
basically changes to exemption or credit
amounts
only become
effective in a community if the
community
re-adopts their tax credits
unless otherwise expressly required in
law
so the question is
does this bill universally change it
for every community are the voters voted
on a certain way does this universally
change what the voters voted on or would
this have to it would only be
able to be implemented on a community
community basis if they vote to
re-adopt their veterans tax credits
and that's all i have
i see none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you and i'm going to
close the hearing
support for
opposed three
and the sign-in sheets
on 1374 we had no sign-ins on the blue
sheet
on 1375 we had
mr control mr michael and mr perry
uh all support
looks like
veteran services
he also supports that
did you guys get that
yes
okay i'm going to open the hearing on
house bill 1056. it's relative to
mr chase representative how are you
today i'm great how are you mr chairman
and thank you to the committee for
letting me introduce house bill 1056 and
act relative to
the veterans tax credits so this bill
increases the amount of the veterans
property tax credits and removes the
requirement that a veteran has at least
90 days of active duty service this
latter part is supported by the state
veterans advisory council
first i'll touch upon the reasoning for
increasing the minimum veterans property
tax credit and increasing the optional
veterans property tax credit range the
reason for increasing the minimum is to
create more equity for veterans across
new hampshire the current fifty dollar
minimum is probably offered in about
looking at the dra's website forty to
fifty communities most of them
uninhabited which is woefully low as
with the other bills i've brought before
this committee fifty dollars today is
not worth the same as fifty dollars two
decades ago yogi berra also said it well
and nicole ain't worth a dime anymore uh
200 minimum would be much better and
more just for all veterans most
communities have a 500
tax credit which uh that they've chosen
to adopt through the optional tax credit
um rsa and the
and which was former the maximum amount
before 2018 uh the optional veterans tax
credit for communities rather than some
veterans getting fifty dollars in the
majority getting 500
all would get at least 200 and most will
receive 500 so rather than some getting
a thousand percent less than the
majority of veterans in this state
most
will get you know the 500 and that small
minority will only get 150 percent less
uh the reason for increasing the
optional veterans tax credit range of uh
up to uh from 201 dollars to 900 is
twofold first a new minimum dollars a
minimum tax credit would require the
lower of the range of the optional
veterans tax credit to increase two
hundred one dollars second seeing that
we would increase the bond with the
range by 150 dollars i thought it would
be fair and logical to increase the
upper of the range by 150 to 900
overall this will not affect anyone
unless communities adopt an optional
veterans tax credit credit higher than
what they're currently offering to
veterans as i mentioned the majority of
communities offer the 500 tax credit a
few taken upon themselves since 2018 to
offer the 750 tax credit this 900
increase of the upper range is not
requiring any community to offer 900 tax
credit it's just allowing communities
the option to offer up to 900
um for the most part no community could
ever adopt you know the higher end of
this range and most communities will
probably stay at the current 500 tax
credit um to help mitigate any possible
costs i made the legislation go into
effect on january 1st 2023 and i gave
communities a three-year phase-in uh for
potential cost to you know to account
for those even though
in most communities this would probably
have you know
probably no tax impact on the majority
of taxpayers um so again thank you for
letting me speak and i'd be more than
happy to take any questions from the
committee if there are any
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
so as you briefly touched upon in your
bill introduction
and as we see throughout the framework
of this bill that you have struck the
language in the requirement for
not less than 90 days of service could
you please explain your rationale for
eliminating that minimum
days of service to be eligible for the
veterans tax credits
um so i can give you my reasoning but i
think the state veterans advisory
council could probably
explain more why their support for it is
because i think it might be different i
found the uh then so in my opinion i
didn't think that there should be
because uh they have they have to have
served in a qualifying in a qualifying
armed conflict right qualifying war or
armed conflict and was honorably
discharged i didn't think that it made
sense to have a time limit for how long
someone fought in a war for the united
states i think if they've been in on the
front lines or you know serving in an
armed conflict for even you know a week
it makes sense for them to also be
treated the same as other veterans
i couldn't really find you know looking
through the past and trying to find you
know previous sponsors of the original
legislation which was you know so long
ago
what the original reasoning was
for having the 90-day duration
requirement
so i thought if i can't find any logical
reason for why it should exist then why
should exist in state law
one follow-up
thank you mr chair um
my understanding perhaps could be the 90
days um
references
um
boot camp and training
so is do i understand you correctly that
perhaps what you're you're advocating is
somebody who washed out of boot camp
unfortunately for whatever reason and
say they were there for one day they
should also be eligible i i think the
language and um from on line 10 in
section under part 4 section
a
it says on active service in the armed
forces of the united states in any
qualifying war or armed conflict i mean
maybe i'm misreading maybe i
misinterpret it but it says in any
qualifying war armed conflict listed in
the section and was honorably discharged
or an officer honorably separated from
service
i think in any qualify i think it
implies that they have to have fought in
that armed conflict or in that war maybe
i'm mistaken though and again that could
be a good question for the state
veterans advisory council to clarify
because they they know a lot more about
how veterans are specifically affected
by this than myself
but thank you for the
questions yeah just one more question
again for the chair
um i also think that it could have been
pretty easy to put together a financial
note for this bill as well
and wondering why we don't have one
okay
notice
anybody else have any questions
so
i was just checking the rsa numbers
that this bill and
the previous bill
um
touch
and um
both both of them seem to mention rsa
uh
uh 28 at some point or another
it mentions honorable discharging um in
the previous one so i'm wondering
um
do you do you think it's necessary to
do any sort of amendment work to
harmonize
the two bills here um
to
maybe
um bring the definition of veteran
um in accordance with the other one or
can they both be
thank you for your question
representative and i'm kind of confused
what you're so you're asking about
72 colon 28 on the definition of a
veteran if we need to update that
in order to be in accordance with this
legislation
because i mean i think this legislation
is just citing 72
i don't even know if that's where the
definition of a veteran is but
i think if you qualify as a veteran
under what the state statute says as a
veteran then you qualify for this
veterans tax credit right if you fought
in
any qualifying war armed conflict which
is also defined in state statute i can
remember the exact um rsa and so
without you know this is just removing
the duration requirements so if you
fought even a day in any kind of
qualifying war armed conflict that's
listed in state statute you would
representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question representative um so
if i understand are you trying to
equalize or create opportunity for the
veterans to get the tax credit across
the state because right now it's
community to community varies from city
to town what the tax credit for uh
housing
um so
every community already has they're
required under state statute to have the
minimum veterans tax credit
right that 50 hasn't been updated for
you know probably well over a decade the
goal of this legislation is not only to
increase it because you know inflation
is you know does a toll on people's
pocket books and on their standard of
living but also by increasing it it
would make it so then the veterans tax
credit is more even across the state as
i mentioned right so the majority of
communities offer you know that offer
the optional veterans tax credit which
is the majority of communities in the
state they offer typically about a 500
tax credit you can go look on the dras
2020 report
now there's a small number of
communities that some of them are
inhabited and some of them haven't
addressed the you know adoption of the
optional veterans tax credit that offer
a 50 tax credit so some veterans are
getting a thousand percent more of a
veterans tax credit than others despite
serving in the same conflicts the goal
of this is to make it so then it's a
little bit more equal right everyone in
every community will get at least two
hundred dollars
but most veterans that are living in the
communities with a 500 optional tax
credit they'll still get that right and
this legislation doesn't change the
optional tax credit for any communities
if you've already adopted an optional
tax credit that amount is the amount
that will stay unless your community
votes to adopt a higher amount or even
theoretically a lower amount which i
would hope no community does that but
theoretically they
could one follow-up
yeah so would you believe or do you
anticipate
this would address the housing shortage
and not
moving the
mobility of the veterans where going to
housing credit
versus
you know kind of evenly distributing
around the state
have you looked at that i haven't
haven't looked at that i mean i assume
this would
maybe some veterans you know that
consider the tax credit when they're
looking to buy a home that they would
consider that but for the most part i
was just thinking about in a way that
you know these veterans serve their
country and that they deserve to retire
in dignity in a home that they've
invested their their equity into right
their time and when they've come back
from you know from an armed conflict or
a qualifying war it's defined by the
state that you know it should be a
little bit more equal there shouldn't be
some veterans that serve in the same
conflict getting 50 and others getting
i feel as if you know it's more fair to
have everyone at least getting 200
even if the majority get 50 and also
increase that range so communities that
so choose to that have the tax base to
do it can increase the uh the um the
veterans tax credit i think with the
inflationary period that we're going
through right now with the increase of
cost of living and housing in the state
and throughout the northeast i think it
makes sense for communities if they want
to to be able to offer a higher tax
credit up to 900 and i also think it's
good for the workforce veterans tend to
be very dependable workers uh they're
you know new hampshire has a very large
percentage of veterans population and we
had a bill in front of my committee
state federal relations and veterans
affairs that you know actually a couple
of them that's going to be working more
to bring veterans to the state i think
this could be one way to bring more
veterans to this state or at least
veterans who are looking to retire which
retiring and buying a home is also
investing in a community so
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh the previous hearing
towns needing to re-adapt
the tax credit
is
thank you for your question
representative could you define re-adapt
like do you mean
uh
no
since
since uh
you're changing the amounts
does that mean that the
for the previous adapt adoption
is no longer valid
i i don't think so not the way the rsa
reads it just allows if a community
wants to adopt a different amount they
can go to the ballot and adopt a
different amount whenever they want um
how i would imagine it working is
currently it's fifty dollar minimum any
community that has a fifty dollar
minimum this would increase their
minimum to two hundred dollars that
would be required by state statute but
any community that currently has adopted
the optional tax credit it wouldn't
change it unless they weren't unless the
current tax credit they had adopted
wasn't was um
was outside was lower than that 200
amount right that 201 dollars so let's
say a community theoretically had a 150
tax credit currently adopted right i
would assume they would automatically
now be the 200 minimum they would have
to maybe re-adopt more than 200 or they
could just choose to deal with that 200
minimum i think when i look there's only
about two towns
that offer less than a 200
um
optional tax credit so i mean there
might be two or three towns in the state
that might have to decide whether or not
you know they want to adopt a higher
amount or if they're just going to deal
with the maybe 50 or 25 dollar increase
of the
thank you mr chairman
[Music]
i
i'm a selectman in hampstead
and
like all towns we get upset when
the state mandates
as anything
that word shall is really you know
that's a dirty word
it's a four-letter word to us
so
uh do you uh recognize the fact that
when you increase even in 500 to the 900
which is still which is optional the
amount of pressure
local communities will feel
from their veterans
in their community
to raise it to 900. so aren't you really
mandating the 900
tax credit because of the way
it's uh it's handled in most communities
um
thank you for the question
representative guthrie i would look at
the um the historical example of 2018 in
passing increasing from 500 to the 750
amount not a lot of communities have
gone to adopt it and for the majority of
the time it might be petition warrant
that does it um it's more of just a
democratic process if there's a group of
residents in the community who are
voters qualified voters or if a border
selector decides to put onto the ballot
you know any kind of increase or
decrease of the uh of the veterans
optional tax credit it's up to the
voters to make that final decision if
they're willing to bear any of that
burden now for the most part i'm going
to address it more in my second
testimony
the amount that the amount of veterans
in each community as a percentage of the
of the taxpaying population is so small
right and the amount of revenue lost is
so minute the majority of communities
the vast majority will not see any kind
of burden shifting
that you might expect so i i'm not sure
if um
i'm not sure if the concern that this
would automatically you know create some
kind of revenue losses would be large
enough for any community not to be able
to deal with especially with the
three-year phased-in approach and i also
think because it's ultimately the
taxpayers who vote to adopt or not to
adopt these tax credits i think they
have the final say and even via if they
want to you know put in a petition
warrant
thank you for your answer thank you mr
chair
thank you so much um
i i have gone over the the
dra um information and so on and
and um my my question to you is that
have you noticed that those that would
be affected by this are smaller towns
and
a smaller town does have a significant
impact and
i look at 50 150
type of things and um for instance the
berlin
berlin has 356 veterans now getting it
at 150 and i know that's only an
increase of 50 dollars per but this does
have an effect on them a place like
hart's location and i will get to my
question yes
a place like hart's location has four
people and they're getting 50 you're
you're asking them to go up and it's a
small community
have you have you talked to any of those
those towns and so on within that area
to find out how they would be able to
handle this because we all know that
when we give a credit we push the burden
on to somebody else which could be young
family and i worked 26 years for the
department of veterans affairs and i
chaired your committee at one point so
i'm all for helping veterans in every
way shape and form i'm just afraid of
this shell what it will do and so my
question to you is have you checked with
those any of those communities that are
impacted by it um i have not and thank
you for your question i have not
um i think i think the bigger thing to
remember is um the majority of the
communities that have the fifty dollars
right now are uninhabited right so if
you look at the dra a lot of those
communities are uninhabited there is a
very small amount that do i think you
also have to remember the percentage of
veterans that live in that community
because that's really what's going to be
able to determine um how much that shift
is and for the most part most
communities in new hampshire except for
you know some very small ones like you
mentioned hearts location right they
obviously have a disproportionate amount
of veterans you mentioned the four
veterans um and i believe hearts
location only has about 20 people that
live there 26 people i believe if i
remember off the top my head their
budgets actually ran i believed by
carroll county's commissioners if i'm
not mistaken
so i could speak to our commissioners
about that specific issue but for the
most part i mean that's a 200 shift for
their entire budget that the county
helps
operate so i still think the amount is
quite small i still think the percentage
of the veterans in these communities is
such a small percentage that the overall
shift when i did the math would um
there'd only be a handful of communities
where it would actually see any kind of
even impact on someone's property tax
bill for the most part
so
are there any other questions for
representatives
okay i see
i would like to call jim mishad back up
again
good morning committee members uh jim
michaud chief assessor for the town of
hudson and i am neutral on this bill
um
just a little bit of research according
to online dra data for 2020 there are 48
communities whose residents have decided
to have their standard veterans tax
credits below 200
including and i was kind of shocked at
this including concord
i went to the website just to confirm
that
concord berlin colebrook and it's true
many small communities but
concord's not small
of the communities that are at the
current maximum of 750
admittedly there's only been a few
cycles a few years since that went into
play 17 out of the 257 taxing
jurisdictions have that upper limit
beyond that
i don't know if it's clear or not if
this goes into effect
that
communities would automatically take
place in those 48 communities or not
so that's kind of above my pay grade um
do they have to re-adopt it or does it
just universally happen
um
the language in the bill covers um the
all veterans tax credit which is a
non-wartime defined tax credit right the
all veterans tax credit was created to
give an ability for communities to offer
a veterans tax credit to those that did
not serve during war defined periods
and that is the only statute
of the veterans tax credits that does
have that three-year phase in
so the others would not you know if it's
mandatory um
you know i guess you could phase in the
all veterans but the other ones would be
would just happen
um and i think the veterans
organizations behind me will speak more
to 90 day active duty requirement but
everywhere i look it seems to be a
universal
minimum number of days of active duty to
acquire most of the va benefits
they all seem to be 90 days or more
but that's that's informal
that's not uh that's not my my expertise
and
i ask myself how many have served less
than 90 days i can't find an answer for
that
google doesn't tell me duckduckgo
doesn't tell me i don't know the answer
to that
maybe dod knows but um i don't know if
most communities are at 500
but the dra does have a list then you
can sort it in excel it's downloadable
and it's very helpful
thank you
okay thank you for your testimony is
there any questions for this witness
representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
when you introduced yourself um
did you say that you're a
assessor for hudson that's correct
all right so so so the automatic
increase from fifty dollars to two
hundred dollars would impact
uh hudson thank you for the question it
would not impact hudson hudson is
currently at uh six hundred dollars uh
effective for the first time in 2021 so
this would not impact hudson
the 90 days
lowering it to less than 90 days would
thank you very much for your testimony
i'd like to now call maura ryan did i
thank you mr chairman
excuse me my name is maura ryan and i am
actually a veteran i usually have a sign
that says i'm a veteran because most
people confuse it and think it's only
men but that's not true
primarily because it impacts many female
veterans who need households because
they have young children
um
essentially many people are coming out
of the military um
they
can't always find housing
and places like harbor homes are not
able to house anyone with young children
the veterans tax credit is very
important because it affects their
ability to maintain housing
i know that i purchased my home in 2013
i got out of the mill i retired i was
retired from the military in 2018.
um in the
eight years i've had my home
my home has been reassessed six times
the most recent assessment in 2021 with
a 1200 increase
as a medically retired veteran that
impacts me because my cola is generally
only one percent which doesn't cover the
increase in my taxes
there are a number of veterans who
wanted to come and speak out on this
because
we're really not in alignment with the
inflation inflation that's going on
right now
and there are many people who are trying
to maintain their homes
vested members of their community many
of them do
community service many of them do a lot
of community service at the va hospital
and
essentially i feel that they're
deserving of the increase in the tax
credit
hi um could you just repeat your name
for us for your note breaking purposes
please sir no problem my name is maura
ryan
thank you mr chair thank you for your
service and thank you for testifying
and you bring out a good point in terms
of the female veterans because when you
think of veterans the image is usually a
male
saying veteran so um and
how many do you
think you have in terms of in new
hampshire or in your community that are
female veterans with young family
that would really significantly benefit
from this this is just one aspect
of your existence right the tax credit
for and then other benefits would help
to get back on the fee well actually for
anyone who comes out of the military um
if you are medically discharged you're
able to collect va disability but you're
not able to get your retirement pay
which is a big negative
and we're trying to work on that as well
but
many of the female veterans the female
veteran population is increasing it's
roughly at 10 percent growing very
quickly
many of them are single parents with
children as well
and there's something called an
apportionment i testified last year on
the apportionment claim that's how we
get
our child support i've been fighting my
apportionment case for 12 years so my
son who's about to turn 18 i've been
trying to get child support for him for
over 12 years so the main thing i rely
on is the va disability i'm not entitled
to retirement pay and i do have to pay
for my son's health insurance through
the department
of defense
thank you
and i did ask at my town just to answer
your question appropriately i did ask at
my town regarding the number of veteran
households they could definitively
identify 35 veteran households our
town is over 10 000 households
and just to follow up with that 35 or
female
uh 35 total total yes both male and
female yes okay thank you
there are some single uh
thank you very much and i hope you
i'm going to close the hearing on
10 56
and open the hearing at 10 30 which is
representative de chase
you want to introduce the bill
uh thank you mr chairman thank you to
the thank you to the committee i think
this is gonna be the last time you guys
see me for uh for the year hopefully
unless i'm mistaken i have to fill in
for someone else for a bill that i'm
co-sponsoring but this is the uh this is
the third
piece of legislation i have in front of
you that regards property tax exemption
or property tax credits um but this
one's the largest of the three that
would have probably the greatest fiscal
impact locally which is um relative to
the tax exemption for the elderly
so this bill would increase income
eligibility criteria for the elderly
property tax exemption it lowers the
eligibility age by about five years and
changes the um the three tiers for the
eligibility and permits municipalities
to phase in the revised eligibility
criteria over a three-year period it
also decreases the duration requirement
from three years to one year much of the
reasoning for this legislation is the
same as house bill 1055 which i believe
i spoke about a week or two ago
introduced to the committee the
legislation relative to the property tax
exemption for individuals with
disabilities and individuals who are
deaf or severely hearing impaired and
the proposed amendment to adjust the
income asset qualifications for the
blind property tax exemption the
adjustment for income and asset
eligibility criteria for the property
tax exemption outlined in house bill
1057 is based upon
the inflation rate from 2008 to 2021
2008 was chosen as a beginning year
because the rsa was last changed in 2008
i chose 2021 because that's when i wrote
the bill last year
the age qualifications would be updated
to three categories people um six years
of age up to seven years of age seven
years of age up to 80 years of age and
80 years of age or older the reason for
updating the age requirement is to allow
more people to qualify and to allow them
to qualify sooner this can help many
people in new hampshire's elderly
communities save their last few years of
income and better plan for their
impending retirement and how they're
going to be able to stretch their dollar
farther people are now living a longer
in this country and so a lot of people
need to plan not so much for a 15 to 20
year retirement but a 30 to 35 year
retirement uh the duration requirement
was lowered from three consecutive years
to one year as i mentioned when i
testified on house bill 1055 i believe
this is almost all
i believe someone buying a home in a
community and making that long that
investment is a long-term commitment
when someone invests their time and
their resources to move somewhere and to
choose to retire hopefully decreasing
the duration requirement will
incentivize people around the country to
retire in new hampshire and make direct
investments in their community and grow
our property tax base overall
choosing to retire in the grand state is
also investing in our local communities
as i mentioned sorry i read that twice
lastly the overall cost of the tax
burden shifting will be so minuscule
that property taxpayers will either not
be affected or not even notice according
to hampshire dras 2020 elderly tax
exemption report no community has a tax
burden shift higher than 4 cents per
thousand dollars of property evaluation
even if communities with the highest
burden shift saw
uh the amount of the tax burdenship
double a home of a 300 000 tax
evaluation which is the average tax a
little bit under the average tax
valuation for the highest average county
rockingham county
even if you know a county like
rockingham county these communities
uh
saw you know a double in this tax burden
ship the total increase would only be
about twelve dollars per year this is
fairly large overestimation right we're
using the communities with the largest
burden shipped with the county with the
highest property tax evaluation so
for the most part most communities will
see increases between zero dollars to
maybe five six seven dollars per
household this trade-off would help
thousands of elderly constituents be
able to stay and keep their homes rather
than having to move into other housing
options and for a lot of folks in a lot
of communities there aren't other
housing options it's either you're in
the home that you bought and put equity
in for the last 30 or 40 years or you're
gonna have to ask a family member to
start subsidizing your living either in
somewhere else in the state or in
another part of the country typically it
tends to be florida
so to help mitigate any possible cost of
this tax um of this tax exemption uh
like with the other two pieces of
legislation made the legislation go into
effect on january 1st 2023 and i gave
communities three years to phase in any
of those potential costs and again thank
you for letting me speak and i will
remain open to any questions are there
any questions for this representative
yes representative
thank you mr chairman and
like the others
there is no fiscal note to this and i do
believe there is a significant fiscal
note that would be attached to this but
i'm so loaded thank you um i i do have a
a question
i i'm looking at um i i did speak to our
um
our
assessing department and so on about all
of these exempt bills and
um i agree
that maybe it doesn't seem like it's a
big burden but when we add them all
together it becomes a burden
um are you aware that
nashua which is my my my city
753 currently are getting the exemption
i don't think it would affect them but
by adding the 60 do you have any idea
the change between 60 and 65
how many people would qualify for that
i'm going to assume you it's kind of i i
would be able to pull that number out of
the air but yeah i think i can make a
rough guesstimate though assuming that
you know obviously the amount of people
who would qualify right obviously
there's going to be more people
qualifying for this tax credit that are
between the age of 60 and 75 than 75 to
older because you know based on people's
average age and how long they live
you're going to have more
younger elderly people that qualify than
older elderly people right not as many
people live to 80 as 60. so i would say
probably um you would see a
disproportionate maybe increase of
of elderly people into the tax credit um
so
i'm not sure exactly what the number is
but you are right there would be there
would be an increase in number of people
qualifying for this tax credit so that's
that's an undeniable truth i'm just
unsure how much of a revenue loss it's
actually going to be for communities or
how much of a um of a tax burden shift
it will be on to other taxpayers like i
said i mean an overestimation of about
twelve dollars per household is um
that's very minute especially when
you're considering the kind of housing
issues that we have the amount of people
of their homes being reassessed in a
number of communities that tend to be
very property tax high communities um i
think i think it's a worthy trade-off
for a number of our communities
may have a follow-up mr chair i want to
follow up
thank you thank you very much um
again i look at the numbers and i look
at
nashua's number of three-point
over 3.2 million dollars in taxes lost
because of the current one manchester
2.279 million dollars
concord is probably about half of that
amount
um adding to this what we do is we push
this down to younger folks that we're
trying to get in here as well do you not
see this as being a negative to
getting more younger people into our
what we're calling ourselves a gray
community a great state
i think most younger people rent so they
wouldn't say directly in their property
tax bill i'm not sure most renters would
increase their rent drastically because
they saw an increase in the amount of
property tax taxes they have to pay go
up by you know 10 to 12 dollars
depending on what kind of home they're
renting i mean obviously i think you
mentioned for example like manchester i
think their current tax burden shift was
only about was it two and a half cents
or was it three cents no maybe it was
only two and a half cents per thousand
dollars which i mean that's actually one
of the lowest tax burden shifts of all
this so it tends to actually be the
larger cities where this tax burden
shift is felt a lot less right
manchester and nashville concord at
least when i look through the dra stuff
so um i would be actually more concerned
about the tax burden burdenship that may
happen in a number of smaller
communities but like i said the numbers
that i brought in front of the committee
today that i explained you know an
average property tax sorry an average
home evaluation tax valuation of 300 000
which is the average in rockingham the
state with the highest average and with
a doubling of the tax burden ship would
probably wouldn't which wouldn't happen
but that's just you know
drastic over estimation if we doubled
the top property tax shift the average
household would only see about a 12
shift so i can imagine any community in
this state where you would see a shift
of over 12 dollars onto someone's total
property tax bill and i like i said
earlier i think the um the overall um
the overall utility of this and
increasing this with inflation because
remember we're just increasing the
amount with inflation
i think it's good it's going to keep a
lot of people in their homes can allow
people to retire with dignity and it's
going to be able to create an overall
net good for our communities right where
more people are going to need less kind
of other subsidies by just not having to
be taxed as much
thank you
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question so
my question pertains to line three
of the build text
and you have reduced the
the residency requirement from three
consecutive years to just one year could
you please explain and expound upon your
rationale for lowering of the residency
requirement thank you yeah so as i
mentioned my testimony today and in my
testimony well first thank you for your
question representative power and as i
mentioned my testimony today in my
testimony on house bill 1055 i feel as
if someone who's either already owning a
home here and making an investment in
their community and choosing to stay and
retire in new hampshire or someone who's
moved to new hampshire who meets the
income eligibility requirements who has
kind of made that investment in their
community in a home
i find the three-year period to be in
and of itself fairly arbitrary
i felt as if a one-year period would
better reflect you know if someone's
going to stay and decide their primary
residency is in new hampshire you know
typically them proving it and staying
here an entire year i would find to be
um enough but i could be maybe i'm
mistaken if someone else has um any
other information for how this could
create some kind of conflict or make it
harder to be able to apply the property
tax exemption
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my follow-up question
um
so there is a dra report in which it
states that
residency requirements
are
within our new hampshire statute are
from three or five years so that's the
data that's the norm
and so i'd like to understand
you have explained why you
um feel that reducing the residency to
requirement you know to one year is
something that you see fit do you have
any um research
or outside
data or inputs that support
uh you are changing it from the three
years to the one year thank you thank
you for your question uh representative
power and so um obviously most of our
property tax exemptions for example the
elderly tax sorry
the disability tax exemption that i
brought before the committee the
duration requirement was five years for
this one it's three years um
i have no specific data for why it's
currently three to five years i couldn't
find on the dras website why that's
currently in state statute and that's
part of the reason why i brought forward
these bills was to update the duration
requirement because i can find
any kind of reason now maybe should i
have done some more due diligence and
maybe try to reach out to direct people
in the dra
possibly yeah and i can definitely do
that for you if you'd like me to
representative power but um i just i
couldn't find a reason why the three to
five year duration requirements were
first originally set in stone and state
statute
thank you mr chair and thank you for
your testimony uh
would you believe that the
bill seems to be
a two issue at least a two if not a
three issue
piece of legislation why would the
income
changes and the
uh the
age
requirements
put in one
put in one bill where they both seem to
be different issues
and in my case i have no problem with
the uh income increases because i i
think the
cost of living and there's a lot of
reasons to make that change but i have a
real
so
the question is why did you put both in
the same bill well uh thank you
representative guthrie for your question
um
i guess just a matter of preference
instead of creating two bills i thought
it'd be better instead of having you
guys have to deal with four bills only
three bills i had some folks that asked
me why don't you put all three of the
pieces of legislation into one piece of
legislation and i said well because
different you know different property
tax credits and exemptions are going to
have different
impacts on communities and i wanted the
community to decide which ones they
thought were the most pertinent right
now which kind of ways that you know
what kind of you know the set priority
to say you know maybe come back in a few
years and try to introduce this one but
you know this one's more realistic i
would not be opposed to the committee
amending this legislation in any way
whether it's changing the eligibility
requirements whether it's changing you
know the age eligibility and everything
if if um you felt it was more than just
to get rid of uh changing the tier the
three tiers you know i wouldn't be
opposed i just want to you know i don't
let the i don't like the perfect get in
the way of the good and if you think
that increasing just for inflation the
income eligibility and asset eligibility
requirement is the best way to go
forward instead of updating the age um i
would not be opposed to that kind of
amendment to this representative guthrie
i'd be more than happy to work with you
to craft it
i appreciate that input thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
i'm just curious why you think 60 is
elderly
because
i'm under 65 but with your bill i would
so why was the age 60 so the reason why
i chose 60 was to give people some time
to be able to take you know especially
folks who might be um
a lot more you know wage workers and
more working class be able to let them
start to save before they go into full
retirement right retirement age now is
typically especially for a lot of state
workers it's like 65 to 67 so being able
to give people that like five years to
be able to start saving and you know the
amount of money that they might save
from the elderly tax exemption right it
might help them be able to starting to
stretch their retirement longer because
people are living longer too
so that was kind of my reasoning and
like i said i mean with any of the three
bills that have brought forward in front
of these committee regarding tax
exemptions i'm more than willing to work
with the committee on amendments to um
to make it more favorable to get an
ought to pass out of this committee i'm
not gonna you know i don't think my
bills are by by any means perfect right
and that's why they go to the committee
for your consideration for you guys to
amend and make them better so i'd be
more than happy to work on whether it's
the age whether it's the amounts that
are in these tax um credits or
exemptions or um etc anything i'd be
more than willing to craft and work with
something i'd even craft it myself if
you sent me an email with what exactly
your points of contention are and you
know i would consider removing them or
seeing where we can find some common
ground
thank you
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
i may not have
stated my question clearly
and with all due respect i feel that you
did not answer the question so the
question that i was asking is did you do
you have any supporting evidence or and
or did you do research that supports
your
desire to change the residency
requirement to one year
you answered my question in the inverse
i want to know
did you do you have any evidence
or do research that speak to or support
the change to one year thank you okay
thank you for your question
representative power and thank you for
uh for clarifying and for holding me
accountable to that um
i have not i don't have any research
that i could give you definitively where
i can show you you know hard numbers of
why it should be one year
but you know as i previously mentioned
is um i couldn't find any evidence for
why three to five years was any better
either
to me it seems like the duration
requirement was subjective it's more of
a matter of you know what the committee
and what the state finds to be best and
maybe you know with the input of local
communities what they might find to be
uh easier to um
to apply and to uh to be able to handle
the burden so um no i have no i have no
verifiable evidence for why one year is
better than three to five but um
you know i haven't seen any evidence
either for why three to five is
necessarily better than one year either
so
i hope that does that answer your
question representative
yes thank you thank you
i see a question from representative
thank you mr chu thank you
representative for taking my question my
question is how did you come up with the
income range what was the benchmark or
what was the reference
you increased
from 13
13 this low end 13 400 to 17 420
and again the high end from
400 to 26
where did you get that
benchmark to move it to that yeah so as
i as i mentioned
in my uh my testimony
the adjustment for income and asset
eligibility criteria for the property
tax exemption outlined in this
legislation is based upon the inflation
rate which is the cpi index that i use
the computer the consumer price index
from 2008 when the legislation was last
updated to 2001. so this is i mean for
all intents and purposes part of the
purpose of why i introduced some of
these bills to the committee was to make
an adjustment for inflation that hasn't
been adjusted i would hope maybe moving
forward you know in subsequent sessions
that we have you know we have um the
asset and income eligibility be tied to
inflation so we don't have to you know
go back every few decades and say oh
look you know the number of people
qualifying for this is at an all-time
low because the legislature hasn't you
know kept up the pace with you know the
yearly rate of inflation which typically
is two and a half percent to now we're
seeing as high as seven percent so um
that's kind of the it's just making an
adjustment so raw i mean i would say
we're not really we're not really
necessarily increasing the eligibility
criteria for the property tax exemption
we're just making it to be in the spirit
of the original state statute that was
established and that people have fallen
out of eligibility because we haven't
kept up to keeping with the spirit of
the law
follow-up mr chairman yeah so
uh if i heard you correctly this wasn't
uh
state uh statute wasn't changed from
2008 yeah that when i went through on
the state's website to look at the last
time this rsa was amended it was 2008
that doesn't necessarily mean that was
the last time the eligibility or the
asset requirements were updated but that
was the last time the law was um
that was the last time this rsa was
changed and you know that there was a
piece of legislation that amended the
rsa um i could definitely try to reach
out to the dra or maybe previous
sponsors or maybe even office of
legislative solutions might have exactly
what that change was in 2008 but um i
just chose 2008 as a good number for
that's the last time the committee
thought it was worthy of updating this
rsa so you know it's been about
13 years i believe so
well now actually 14. so it's been 14
years and maybe it's time for us to look
at this and kind of consider how things
change how how new things brought to
light make us reinterpret this and how
as people's income has been affected by
inflation
representatives
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
my eye keeps going back to
uh line
three
on page two of the bill
and i just i have to ask
if we require
married couples
to have been married to each other for
at least five years
for their property to qualify for this
exemption
why that wasn't changed in your proposed
what is the purpose of being married for
five years
how does that
make you more qualified for the
exemption than somebody who maybe got
married within the last 90 days
well the primary homeowner you know
would still
qualify within the one year
right so i guess um
[Music]
i guess so kind of how i looked at it
was someone
there's sometimes a fear where you know
a statue like this could incentivize
people to get
married for legal purposes and not for
you know some of the um
some of the other you know some people
believe that marriage is just something
that should be a spiritual thing um
but so i felt as if making it based upon
land ownership might be better rather
than the uh the marriage but that's
certainly something i'd be more than
willing to look at and to entertain an
amendment for
so by that logic then changing it to
the residency requirement to one year
could that not be seen as
inducing some people to
move to a town
to acquire a property that would have
this exemption i agree and that was part
of the purpose of this i feel as if
someone's going to make an investment in
a community that's a good thing overall
for the community
i mean if they're going to decide to um
well first we have to remember the
people who qualify for this it'd be very
tough for them to
originally kind of um to buy a home for
a lot of the people that qualify for
this they're already existing in their
home right they and their income has
decreased and their assets have
decreased because they're getting ready
for retirement right so they were
previously making one amount of money
they've now retired and they're living
off of pension or their social security
so that's um that's one thing but for
the number of people that you know in
the very rare circumstance where they've
saved up money and you know have decided
that they're going to relocate i think
it's good that someone might relocate
make an investment in a home spend that
money you know have contractors in the
area helping them refurbish that home
and everything and for them to then you
know settle down and to become
participating members of the community
so the incentive i agree with you i
think it's a good incentive personally
but maybe i'm mistaken
thank you okay are there any other
questions for this witness
okay i'd like to wrap it up if anything
else has been talked about before we
want to continue that so go ahead
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question my question pertains
lines fourteen through seventeen where
you talk about the phase-in period over
phase-in of this over a three-year
period could you briefly just describe
what that looks like and and how would
that work thank you
so
i think it'd be very community dependent
communities would decide how to phase it
in and i'm not sure i mean the last time
like i said this legislation was updated
was 13 years ago 14 years ago now
because we're in 2022. um to put that
kind of in perspective in 2008 i was
nine years old so i'm not really i'm not
really entirely sure how communities
each in you know in different regions in
different areas we're deciding to phase
this in um but it would be very
community dependent based on how our how
based on how this section three is
written and i take the section through
exactly for langu for the previous
language that was in the originally
passed
legislation that allowed for people to
phase in this property tax credit i also
used in the other ones because i felt
it's a very good approach it allows a
certain amount of local control and
local latitude to decide based on
community revenues of how they're going
to be able to phase this in and how much
they're going to um you know increase to
get to the total state uh required
amounts
i see none representative
thank you very much thank you for having
me and thank you to the committee would
anybody else like to testify on this
bill
i see none i'm going to close the
hearing for
absolutely
well noted thank you
the others are
online and i did pass those two
references
foreign
i spent 35 years in higher education
administration 21
and i
retired
and i just about went up of course you
get enough
and now i manage the cash office
i don't want week classroom anymore i
want to be the assistant
he'd ask me for those links at the dra
this
is
um
we're not even waiting to stabilize to
find out how they're affecting the
community
representatives davis i think i agree
with you that that last bill
seems to penalize
i don't think that was my intent i just
couldn't kind of
get the numbers to jive in my head like
why five here and one there and three
i don't think we shouldn't be
should we be
advertising that we have a rebate for
i thought lynn
massachusetts was the only town that
favors that
are you kidding you still can't buy
liquor in massachusetts on sundays
sure
okay
my town wants this my county wants this
my city deserves this
the only bills that i create we should
yes you said
uh
um
okay
yes
thank you mr chairman
good morning mr chairman and honorable
members of the municipal and county
government committee
i come before you
my name is excuse me suzanne vale and i
am a new hampshire state representative
from nashua ward 3 which is hillsborough
county district number 30.
i come before you to ask for favorable
consideration of house bill 1342
which is relative to the municipal
charter provisions for tax caps
i filed this bill when i learned that
the legislation that came out of this
committee
the last
year
became law but looking at the bill i
felt like it still needed some
clarification
and so
going through the bill it reverses
changes made by senate bill 52 which was
filed on behalf of nashua former
officials who were unable to have the
courts stop nashua
from passing a budget
although the former officials were found
to have standing to sue the city the
outcome was that this tax spending cap
in nashua was not constitutional due to
having no override
provision
this bill adds that override provision
where it does not currently exist
so if you look on line seven of the bill
it adds this in
in any circumstance in new hampshire for
a city that has a tax cap
there will automatically be an override
at least that's the intention of what
it also removes two very long clauses
where the law attempts to make an
override an exclusion
to be the same thing and they're not
they're two separate acts and they're
even two separate votes
as the law stands right now this flaw
exists and like all flaws found in the
law it will open up municipalities for
further time in court over
interpretation
during the hearings that preceded the
change in the law it was stated
repeatedly that the language being added
which is now stricken from this
present bill before you would be
problematic as it was inconsistent with
the requirement to have an override
provision
um
house bill 1342 remove removes a lot of
the confusing language
that was pointed out by municipal
experts during the hearings last year
but to be less confusing and to have
equivalences that aren't real
on
on in state law is probably a worse
in the case where tax cap does not have
an override position provision it is
here
and although we understand that this has
been a nashua problem
and
the reason why there aren't co-sponsors
from other places in the state are is
because this is very clearly a natural
problem and i hate to bring our problem
before you
as
a former member of the municipal county
government committee i know what that
means
so i humbly come before you
and apologize
um
the other thing this bill does
is in the very first line
actually in the second line the third
it's notwithstanding rsa49b
colon one
um
and the um the
on line four before july 5th 2011.
um
this bill does it
this this bill wants to undo that
because it feels that the other bill
had too many things going on in it at
the same time
i am not a municipal lawyer i'm happy to
take any kind of questions i'm also not
present seated in the nashua city
government in any way i was not
approached to file this bill by anyone
in nashua city government i decided to
file it when i heard the testimony and i
was very concerned that our family
problem will bring problems to other
cities like rochester
manchester
um
laconia franklin
and i have in support of the bill
members have signed up
who are from these areas and so their
i think that's it
for those of you who keep track of this
signed up to support this bill while 47
oppose it
so
does anyone from the committee have
questions
for our representative yes
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative my
question pertains to page one lines
seven through nine in which you insert
the language shown in bold
to
institute an override of provision upon
two-thirds major super-majority vote of
the governing body
so
it's my understanding that currently
under our current statute that in fact
every tax and spending cap in new
hampshire
whether enacted before or after july 5th
does in fact contain a super majority
override provision
as provided for in sb52 that was passed
as you stated
back in 2021
june
june 21st so my question is why is this
new necessary language why is this new
language necessary if in fact
all tax and spending caps in new
hampshire have that provision could you
um thank you for the question
i don't see where it says that all
spending caps already have this in fact
in my research i don't see it anywhere
and then the supreme court decision
it was
we were found to have no
um
an unenforceable tax cap because of the
fact that it didn't have an override
position provision into it
and um
the way that it's the way that it came
through and sb 52 doesn't correct that
and that's that's all i have for you
representative mindy poody
thank you mr chair are you glad to have
thank you representative whale for
taking my question
isn't it true that this
tap back
tax cap
is only spending cap is only
in
nashua and we are the only privileged
city to have this in the state and it
kind of and you alluded to it by saying
this is our problem our family we don't
want to bring it to
the state but state is imposing this
isn't that correct
um let me try to clarify thank you for
i guess the best way to put that is that
in nashua people are suing the city over
their tax cap
in other cities
they have not been tested on their
decision making in the courts
however
state law is state law and there are
other cities
with tax caps and i'll just make an
example rochester
um and this does affect them but in
rochester they are not being taken into
court so they have not been told
that their um that their
capitalism is
unenforceable
and so this is attempt to make it
enforceable for everyone without adding
exclusions and other language that has
been found to be confusing in the past
and to to change what's already gone
through the supreme court may bring us
right back into the supreme court
and i wouldn't wish that on any town
thank you
thank you representative klee
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony and for full disclosure i
am
a an alderman in um in nashua
so
this does impact us and um
representative vale is as you're aware
it was the spending cap that we went to
the supreme court with that said it was
um unconstitutional because our spending
cap did not have any form of override
this
bill my first question is if i may this
bill is not to
eliminate what the the general court did
last year correct it's it's just to put
in this override and ensure that the
override has the two-thirds majority
keeping with what we believe was
probably the intention of the
of the original bill is that correct
yes it is it is intended to
carry forth the intention of the
original
statute
and unfortunately in our tax cap we did
we were not in compliance with this and
so we that was something that we needed
to
address
in our own town and that's where i say
this is just our it's not just our
problem it's our problem because we
brought it
it's your problem because we brought it
to you and for that i apologize
it's our problem because yes yes please
thank you again mr chairman thank you um
the the spending cap not the tax have
because we don't have a tax that we have
a spending cap in nashua the spending
cap um
to the best of your knowledge um
effects even getting
i hate to use the word free money
because nothing is ever free but um
grants and so on it affects us how we um
whether it affects our spending in other
words if we accept a grant and we spend
the money does it not affect that and
not having an override can have a
negative effect on it and that's what
this is to correct is that is that
correct
yes there are many cases where we would
have met the cap
and then after the fact received grant
money or received money from the federal
government of some type that we're
having difficulty to
work into the into this situation in
fact i'm not even sure what happens and
um and i appreciate the question
representative clee because i do wonder
do we refuse the money i mean i haven't
had the time to go into this as deeply
as i would have liked to over the past
month as
as i've been um i'm sorry but i've been
out with an illness so
um but at the same time thank you for
no i just wanted to answer her question
if we would have to refuse it no no
we'll
okay thank you so much
i'll make note of it
yes uh thank you for your testimony
today
um
in the city of nashua can you
tell me
first
how was the
spending cap or tax cap
first put into place
what was the was there a vote of the
townspeople to put that in place
there was a excuse me thank you for the
question there was a referendum boat
held at the time
and i believe that the tax cap was put
into place in 1993
and i want to say that we had another
referendum on in
2014 that was related to this
and i looked for the language in that
referendum actually i was looking for
the question and i couldn't find it
so i'm sorry to not have that available
but i can try to find what the ballot
question was in 2014 and send that to
you if you would
care for that yes a follow-up please in
line number nine
you say it shall be
there should be an override upon a
two-thirds super-majority vote of the
governing body can you define the
well in this case in nashua would be the
one more follow-up
so
if if the tax cap was put in place
as a result of a referendum of all the
voters in nashua
shouldn't the governing body be
i really appreciate that question um i'm
honestly stumped
i'm not sure
that
um
that is a very inclusive
idea of what the referendum is what i
can say about the referendum issue and
what i might have a problem with is
where we get into using
language like exclusions and exceptions
instead of the word override and what
the people voted on was an override
that's what they understand that's what
they know
that's what they go by they don't go by
any other terminology that was
introduced by senate bill 52
thank you
thank you and i want to go back to
representative cleve
i
turned you down when you wanted to
help with answering a question
let me
be a little more
explanatory and maybe a little more
lenient on that
if you
can say what you want to say in the form
of a question
you can you can do it like and
would you believe
type of thing if you want you want to
start like that and i'll let you i'll
let you go on that direction
thank you mr chair and i do have a
another question after that but i'll
leave it up to you as to whether or not
i can continue
um
i'm never very good at
this guess i could do the would you
believe um
you had question about the the the grant
monies and um
would you believe that unless
the money was anticipated and budgeted
that that money would have to in fact be
turned back if it brought the city
beyond
the um spending cap and it's not a tax
cap it's a spending cap
where
because
a spending cap affects
spending and not tax because it's tax
you said yes
thank you yes
even a follow-up also uh
yes um
to to a question that another
representative had had asked about
the two-thirds to the entire
city
where nashua would you believe that
nashua does their budget annually and we
would have to anytime we had an override
like this we would actually have to call
for a special election at a very high
cost to the entire
public hearings
that's my would you believe
the best of my ability to do i i would i
would certainly believe that and i
i guess that even
that explains why i'm stumped by the
question it's just like overwhelmingly
mind-blowing to me that we could ever
that that's what it would bring us to i
mean we would be voting on everything
if we could vote on one thing and that
would change our town of our form of
town government
our city government so
um thank you for the question and i hope
i've
reflected back to you what we were
hoping to get at thank you so much
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative vale i'm sorry i can't
see you
if there was a natural emergency
that
had a severe impact on the city of
nashua
and the city of nashua wanted to sign a
memorandum of understanding with several
or one charitable organizations in the
area that would bring in funding from
other agencies or private donors to
address the natural emergency
that was and then the funds collected
for that purpose exceeded the spending
cap
would you then not be able to use those
funds
you would not be able to use those funds
next we're going to have uh testimony
from julie smith if she's here you'd
like to come on up thank you
representative
thank you and i really appreciate your
welcome
is the red light on
okay thank you mr chair
julie smith from nashua i oppose hb 1342
as a resident of nashua and daughter of
an accountant i want to remind the
committee that money does not grow on
trees i'm here to oppose this bill
simply put it's garbage just look at the
docket 100 sponsored by vindictive
nashua reps
it nashua has a revenue
excuse me does not have a revenue
thank god i do in the senate
and
this bill is just a spiteful revenge
against my senator who happens to be a
good man and the sponsor of sb 52
a very necessary last resort protection
from the unrestrained city hall
frivolousness with our hard-earned
taxpayer dollars the donchias donkeys
and their scofflaw leader are spendless
rift attorney are incapable of that very
offensive please
i'd ask that you
tone down your your rhetoric and make
sure that you're addressing the bill
specifically and not name call or
calling out other members of the
legislature
okay i haven't mentioned any names
um
mister just chair just an objection in
terms of calling people donkeys and
uh vindictive that is very offensive and
i serve on this committee
and i'm from nashua i take it personally
to say this is offensive thank you
thank you mr chair um as already
mentioned um
this committee has two natural reps one
is a co-sponsor and one is an alderman
and i'd like to know how that's not a
conflict of interest
but finishing up here
alderman former alderman t boom
who
committee members should already be
familiar with um
has sent in his testimony about this
bill
and just look at a few things no
personal names mentioned but um the
performing arts center and its bond
situation then there's the replacing of
elm street school with its ever growing
price tag yet enrollment is expected to
decline oh and let's not forget the
myrtle street projects with their
expansion all and all of its associated
hidden expenses ready to surface in the
form of consequences in the years to
come
and did any city employees get
furloughed in the coveted closures of
city hall library schools or other city
entities while countless private sector
employees were sent to the unemployment
line and back to that art center in 2017
my alderman said he didn't care that it
was a money pit and that he wanted it
anyways sadly for the whole city and not
just his constituents he was reelected
in the past two elections and the next
opportunity to get rid of him is not
until the end of next year
this bill is not about new hampshire as
previously mentioned it is about nashua
if it was about other cities
other
city people would be jumping on the
sponsor bandwagon this is a baseless
attack on sb
sb 52 please kill this bill today
thank you for the time
thank you just for the record uh you
mentioned
um representative t boom i have no
i have no uh former alderman
i have no testimony from him or any
input from him
i believe he was in touch with
representative diane power
[Music]
yes representative thank you mr chair um
in fact
mr t boom i noticed
sub uploaded his testimony on the new
and revised general court website so
that is where his testimony is located
and it's available for any member of the
public to view it thank you for that i
don't
just so i so you all know i don't have
any
requests for testimony and i have no
inputs
from that website
which is disappointing but
that's just the way it is
yes representative
um
while i disagree with mr t boom we did
get an email from from him so we do have
something in his uh in the um in our
emails
thank you
is there anybody else that has any
comments or questions for miss smith
yes
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
i'm wondering how
the people who are making the decisions
of spending in nashua which i understand
you disagree with
are they elected by the people in nashua
or are they appointed
i mean are
are the the residents of nashua
selecting who they want to make these
decisions
well there's evidence out there that the
voting machines are selecting them but
it's inconclusive
okay thank you
questions from the committee
saying none thank you very much thank
you mr
chair there anybody else from the
audience or from the committee would
seeing none
i'm going to open the hearing on 13.50
well i gotta wait two more minutes
before i can do that so
you know the thing is that
there was a conversation about let's try
the
body let it be but let's just fix it so
nashville has the ability to override i
very specifically went and looked and
all if there was a majority i changed it
i said that you should search
um
it's looking i think it's looking
favorable
to be
settled pretty soon i don't know any of
the aspects that would be inappropriate
for me to know any of the negotiations
but we did just pass the supervisors and
the paris
um and
and they kind of restructured it and and
the food service so we restructured it
so that they work on a grade scale
with a step increase annually up to for
like 20 years i think it is
the way that they are yeah
you
i'm going to get started again on our
which would be hb 1350.
before we get too deep into that though
i want to mention we are having some
administrative issues with
how people
can put input into the into our
legislative system so that those of us
who are committee members can see it
prior to the
the hearings
and that's been brought forward to the
folks who manage that for us it's a
relatively new system
uh
like you probably heard me in the last
uh hearing that i hadn't heard from mr t
boom well his testimony had been input
unbeknownst to me and it went into our
system
that doesn't automatically come to
all of you
unless you go search for it
that's that's to me is that's a uh
that's a
limitation in our system that needs to
be fixed so that so that if you are a
representative you don't have to go
search for a testimony it should come
right to you
so we're going to be working on that
it's not a
it's not a failure of our ability to
keep
keep moving forward but it's a
limitation and that we should recognize
the fact that from time to time we're
going to have people
who have submitted testimony that we're
not going to see beforehand and i would
hope that we would
educate each other
if if you are aware of testimony that's
sitting out there
and
as the chairman if i'm not
and i mentioned that i haven't seen it
if you have i would appreciate it if you
bring it up so we can
all be enlightened
okay this next bill
is 1350 which is
regarding the procedure for evaluation
of property tax
catherine heck that would like to speak
[Music]
you don't have to defend it just
thank you mr chair and thank you
honorable committee members
it's my privilege to introduce to you
today house bill 1350
relative to the procedure for valuation
of property for property tax purposes
the purpose of the bill is to allow
residents to petition the local
governing body to conduct a full
re-evaluation of property for property
tax purposes
thank you thank you
and catherine heck are you here
please come on up
and you uh
you oppose the bill and you'd like to
speak to it so the floor is yours
thank you mr chairman and committee
members good morning my name is
catherine heck representing the new
hampshire municipal association today
nhma opposes house bill 1350
not for the reasons of having a reval or
the citizens right to request that but
because there are already four avenues
within the law that allow for the
petition for reassessments the two most
common are the board of tax and land use
appeals and the dra those are most
commonly used however
rsa 71b allows a petition to the
governing body by individuals or by 50
taxpayers in the district or a third of
the taxpayers of the district to have a
reevaluation which is a lower threshold
than what the bill currently contains
as well as by petition warrant article
under rsa 39.3 which also then would
have a lower threshold
which would be 25 or more of registered
voters in that case or a 2 percent of
registered voters in the municipality
rsa 71b does prescribe an orderly
process and set forth sets forth
criteria procedures and how expenses
associated with any kind of reassessment
should be handled and further this bill
doesn't define what full value
revaluation is
we are
unsure of the purpose or the intent of
this legislation as it seems to be
redundant
as there's already approved ways for
which
residents taxpayers can
move forward with the reevaluation
process should they have questions
i can now take any questions anybody
from the committee have a question for
nhma
yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you for your
testimony so uh
from your testimony uh am i correct in
understanding the avenues already exist
multiple avenues exist
this will create of
additional more confusing am i correct
or
will it counter any of the existing
avenues
it looks to create a fifth avenue an
additional avenue however there's some
confusing language in it as
i stated not defining the full
revaluation for instance
so that would be one area and we just
believe that we're not sure what problem
this is currently trying to address this
bill
thank you apparently uh
three folks have
brought forth their support for this
bill while 18 oppose it more questions
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
from the nhma
point of view are are you aware of the
the cost of
a municipality having to
do
an evaluation especially a full
evaluation and i'm not really sure if
they're talking about a full measure and
list
or if they're just talking about doing a
city-wide reevaluation but in either
case the cost are you aware of the cost
of revel
outside of the normal procedure and what
it would do to somebody's budget etc
yes we are very aware of the cost they
are extremely
time and cost
it would be cost prohibitive
and we again agree believe that this
bill would not
solve for any problem that is currently
not already addressed in the law
just uh think about your
report of
support and oppose
and i'm
thankful for my colleague here
representative gilman that's looking
online
looks like there is three support and 28
opposed
could it be that people can still
do it while we are in session until it
closes so it could be a discrepancy of
10 opposed
yes uh
so i'm just documenting that as of you
know from your data to
the current online it's already a 10
difference
thank you
any other questions from the committee
yes representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question ms heck
so in your testimony you had stated that
under current new hampshire statute we
already have four avenues by which
residents may petition the local
governing body to
do a re-evaluation of property could you
please explain
some situations or circumstances
in which
this type of re-evaluation might be
warranted or necessary thank you
representative i don't want to dodge
your question i do not have specific
circumstances however i do have an
assessor jim mishow who would be willing
to speak or might have more information
on that so your question can be
addressed thank you
and his name was jim
michoud jim misha
uh mr misha would you like to come up
and
try to tackle that question from the
representative
[Music]
uh representative powell you want to
re-ask your question
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
michoud for taking um my question so my
question was
miss heck had stated that under current
new hampshire statute we already had we
do have four avenues by which the
residents may petition the local
governing body to do a re-evaluation of
property and my question is
if you could please explain or provide
examples or reasons why
such a re-evaluation of property may be
necessary
well uh jim misho chief assessor of town
of hudson thank you committee members
so uh communities are required
constitutionally and statutorily to go
through a reassessment of property once
so
if let's assume somebody's you're in
your second or third year after your
last rebel
and um you have residents property
owners uh who
uh have noticed that the ratio
is out of whack your your annual
assessment ratio each community
develops with the dra
and not maybe just that the assessment
ratio is out of whack but how far you
disperse from that median ratio how how
equitable so if you're at a median ratio
of 80
um do you disperse from that by 10
points 20 points there are statistical
measurements that the dra would use the
statistical measurements that assessors
use btla would use um so it's it's
conceivable that you could get into a
situation where you have an inequitable
situation
that happens before the five years are
mr misho um
could you explain a little bit for the
committee the uh the numbers we hear so
often the
the 90 to 90 to 100 110 numbers and what
they mean for a community
thank you for uh giving the question to
me
so uh in the year of reevaluation
hudson's going through a reevaluation
for this year 2022. our goal is to head
100 of market value
in the statutes they defined uh full and
true market value as between 90 and 110
that's meant to allow for
um it becomes
difficult especially we go to a smaller
community
um to always hit that sweet spot of 100
and so there's an allowance to be plus
or minus 10 of full and true market
value even in the year of reassessment
um and and that can happen because the
economy is uh the housing market's a
little disjointed um that can happen for
a variety of reasons um but that's
that's that's our standard that we are
that we are held to for reassessment and
so they measure the qualified sales that
happen in your community dra
and then they compare that to the
assessed value
for all of those and that's how the
median assessment ratio is arrived at
that's a very quick way of describing
that thank you
are there any other questions for miss
heck or mr micho
yes sir
my good friend
thank you mr chair uh and thank you mr
micho for taking my question i think
it's directed at you am i to understand
that if you had a cod if it was at a
hundred percent there still could be a
petition
a legal petition that could come through
for a reval
for which then the town would be
obligated provided there wasn't a
spending cap that they were in if that
wasn't a problem they would be required
then to do another reval
um thank you for asking the question i i
believe you meant if the community is at
an assessment ratio of 100
and the community had a warrant article
telling it to do another reassessment
that's my question that that is above my
pay grade that is a that is a legal
question that's not a dodge that is a
legal question i believe thank you thank
you representative any other further
questions
yes
representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh
since we have to do a uh reevaluation
every five years i i can assume that
it's a staggered reevaluation
would the reason for
uh requesting evaluation be due to
uh
people that have just been re evaluated
uh due to the increase in their
valuation uh
feel that they're
thank you for the question
representative um i people have all
sorts of reasons i would imagine why
they feel a reassessment should be done
one of them could be that um if the
average increase in the community for
assessed value not taxes assessed value
is 30
if they went up 31 percent they may feel
that's wrong
right and so they may want to pursue
that
um on the other hand
folks could
look at the results of a
re-evaluation and
and discover that the coefficient of
dispersion was higher after the
re-evaluation than it was before the
re-evaluation so there's less equity you
actually created less equity as a result
of rebel i don't find that to be a
common occurrence anecdotally
the department of revenue provides
oversight of every reassessment that's
done in the state um so they see
advanced information and i i would not
find it likely
that
we'll say a a less than good revaluation
uh would be able to reach its conclusion
before somebody raises the alarm at the
state level to the board of slackman to
the local governing body
i don't know if that answers your
question follow up hold up please
uh
well
dairy does its re-evaluation
like
20 percent every year
and uh
there are there are people that when i
was on the console would come to me and
say well we just got reevaluated and my
taxes went up you know 50
that doesn't seem fair and i would ask
them
well do you ever consider that maybe you
were under paying your taxes
does is that the sort of rationale that
you believe would be a
cause for a re-evaluation
request
um thank you for the question i'm i'm
having a little difficulty i i think in
derry you guys uh had been in a in a
cycle of data collection where 20 of the
property had somebody visit it
on site
maybe do an interior not today
but maybe do an interior and certainly
do an exterior review
so they're they're confirming data right
is the data correct
i don't think that they were reassessing
that 20
to full and true market value and
leaving the other 80 percent
i don't know that that's what derry was
doing i i think they were and hudson has
done a cycle of data collection where
we're confirming data so yep now is a
finished basement and there's a pool and
people didn't know they had to get
permits i guess and um now now their
assessment went up a lot but they're not
being assessed to phone through market
value we're just correcting data
pool is there pool is not there things
like that um and it's a good it's a good
process to go through to to cleanse your
data for lack of a better word
thank you mr micho um
in order to keep our records straight uh
historically could i get you to fill out
one of these pink cards
of course yes and miss heck you can help
him uh they're over there
any other questions
yes representative please
uh thank you mr chair and uh thank you
ms michael for taking my um my question
um
we we all know that um if all things
were equal and every house went up ten
percent we wouldn't see any change in
anybody's tax
taxes paid and so on as they say is as a
river uh rises all boats float
and and you pointed out that the dra
approves the rio valley and makes
corrections
however
right now we have this statute of every
five years but can communities whether
it be city or town
do this more often i i've heard of other
communities
they do it once a year to capture the
growth of the
um
of how value evaluations are changing
from small homes to large homes etc
is that correct
thank you for the question
representative certainly communities can
decide to do more do it more often than
once every five years um five years is
is the de minimis
um but um i want to say concord where we
are here um does a frequent reassessment
um and for a variety of reasons um and
and
restoring assessments to full and true
market value
i know when the i know when the market's
going to tank in hudson right it's the
day after we sent out notices of new
value this summer
um and i have testified in front of my
board of selectmen that um well we do
have a capital reserve account um please
can you up it a little bit to put money
in there and i gave that exact scenario
i don't think you want to wait until
in hudson if the market goes south and
um and we could go south equitably right
a dispersion could be nice and tight 10
or less
but we could be at 130 percent of market
value
it's no different than being a 70 of
market value but if you tell somebody
you're assessing them above 100 of
market value um you you are you are not
looked at as uh very kindly
representative
thank you mr chair thank you mr mishap
for your testimony and your patience um
so
would you believe that
the
real estate market you know the
assessment
follows the ups and downs of the peak
and ebb of the real estate market
correct so it's always difficult to
catch up
you know when it's low nobody's going to
come back and say you know my assessment
my value house of value has gone up so
i'll pay more taxes but when it goes up
taxes go up that's when we so would you
believe that it is
the five-year framework
is to give that
cushion and the
option for people to
say if my home is assessed too high
i have avenues
today to uh ask for a reassessment or
reconsideration
thank you for the question
representative so
um if if i feel my individual assessment
is incorrect whether it's in the year of
reassessment or in any other year in
between
um i have it's rsa 7616. i have an
abatement process that i can file for
tax abatement and then if i don't like
what the community's said about that
i can pursue it to the next level vortex
i'm going to feel superior court
a reassessment of the community is more
like
me and the folks in my condo complex
took a look at all the condos and
we found that that strata was pretty out
of whack
using statistical measurements um i
could go to the community
all the things that catherine had uh
discussed i go to the community and ask
them to do it i could do a petition in
local residence to do it
the more likely route
my dad did this in the early 90s before
i was in the business
is you petition the btla you do your
assessment ratio study you run your
stats and um you get the community
either forced to do it or the community
goes up to btla and says my goodness
they're right um and and then the btla
will will assume
ownership of the rebound they'll monitor
it and they'll make sure benchmarks are
met um this is being done in a couple of
city a couple of communities
currently um but it's not the norm um
because because communities 175 seems to
work
and it's not cheap um you know hudson we
were able to get our
statistical update it's a reassessment
of property without
hitting every house physically we've
already done that
but we were in this 15 to 20 dollar
range and we have 10 000 parcels
so a full reevaluation is going to be
north of 15 to 20
and it's all dependent upon
workers labor what's the market like
and
what standards do they have to meet
according to statutory law and
administrative rule
thank you are there any other questions
presenters there any other
comments or questions from the audience
that would like to participate at this
point
thank you both for uh for your testimony
and
we look forward to uh
exacting this uh this bill probably in
the net within the next two weeks
okay uh we're gonna take a break for
lunch
and you have something you want to bring
up
for anybody who missed it the new
hampshire housing finance authority
had a presentation last
tuesday by karen peralic from opticos
design on missing middle housing
the tape is up on the new hampshire
housing finance authority's website
until
mid-february i really recommend that
everybody go take a look at it it's a
really clear explanation
of what missing middle housing is why we
need more of it and how to get it
get a glass of wine it's it's an hour
but it's an hour well spent um so that's
all
um and it's on as i say it's on the
nhhfa website
um there's a hot link to it
okay thank you i'm going to close the
hearing on house bill 1350
and break for lunch
and
come back here by one o'clock and we'll
okay
you're gonna be okay for friday
the biggest thing is you take all the
parts
and put the new ones in joe joe we're
going to be just executing bills on
friday
twelve
oh
please
friday
hey
you
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
my name is norman silber i'm a state
representative from belknap district 2
to the towns of guilford and meredith
thank you
um
this is my second non-consecutive term
i'm also on the executive committee
of the belknap county delegation
and i'm also the chair of the duly
constituted investigative committee
formed by the belknap county
delegation
we i've had passed out to you
the in the copies of the enabling
legislation
as previously amended for gun stock
because
it's somewhat obscure and hard to find
on the websites
because it was never folded into the
rsas there were session laws that just
sort of stood alone and never folded
into our says
in addition
after the colored separator
there is a copy of the last financial
statement from the gunstock area
commission
and that's sometimes a little bit more
hard to find not as hard to find as the
legislation
the reason i'm here is that
we and reason i introduced this bill
is that
the executive committee of the
delegation
has just concluded
many days and many hours of examination
of the proposed budget for belknap
county as proposed by the county
commissioners
we have made adjustments to a variety of
line items
and are going to forward our
recommendations to the full delegation
for a vote to adopt a budget i suspect
there may be a few
minor adjustments made at the delegation
full delegation level
but most of the adjustments were made at
the executive committee level
the the one page loose leaf the loose
page that i've circulated shows the
17 areas of county operations budget of
departments and functional areas
what their annual expenditures were and
how many general ledger line items
were reviewed in the budget review
process by the executive committee
you will see that the largest number was
in the nursing home that had 11.5
million dollars in expenditures and we
reviewed 165
separate line items
over several days i might add
in each of these departments
we don't purport to be experts in
nursing homes
or sheriff's departments or corrections
departments
but we ask that the heads of these
departments come there
tell us about
their departments what they're doing and
why they're asking for the money that
they're asking for
to give you an example the sheriff's
department
budget request was a half a million
dollars more than the prior year
and he wanted three new cruisers and in
the course of the
evaluation by the executive committee
we basically adjusted it so that he'll
get one new cruiser instead of three new
cruisers
um
that goes throughout you know throughout
the all the different departments
you will see that the gunstock area
commission based on their lace financial
statement
had expenditures of
about over a hundred thousand dollars
more than the nursing home which was the
largest expenditure in the county
and
the number of line items for the gun
stock area commission that were reviewed
by
the delegation or its executive
committee
was exactly zero
because under the present law and the
enabling statute
gun stock area commission is governed by
a five-member commission appointed by
the delegation
right now is there is a vacancy it's
basically deadlock two to two there's a
meeting tonight to appoint
a person to fill that vacancy
but right as it stands now the existing
legislation gun stock
with this huge amount of expenditures
sets its own budget in its own way and
makes its own expenditures in its own
way
without any
input from the delegation
and without any approval by the
delegation or any review by the
delegation
so we get we get some anomalies
now you're going to hear from
some folks
in opposition
and what's been interesting is in this
particular issue
between this legislation and the feeling
of this vacancy
several members of the executive
committee of the delegation
have been subjected to a well-financed
vituprative
campaign of public
public letters public advertisements
personal attacks and lies
all in an effort to
leave gun stock alone and let them do
their thing because they had a good year
this past year
and they would like to think that the
reason they had a good year was because
of their managerial expertise
when in reality the reason they had a
good year was because of covet limiting
people from going to more distant places
for skiing and because the ski weather
was good
and when one of those things doesn't
occur when the ski weather when the snow
weather is bad as it has been in the
past sometimes
they don't do as well and a few years
ago
after having a season or two of bad snow
they actually couldn't pay their bills
and had to turn over some of their bonds
that they were paying directly
to the delegation to pay out of county
funds
gun stock is a county-owned property
the money in the gun stock treasury is
taxpayer money
there is in my view and the view of my
co-sponsors and other other supporters
no reason why
this their budget process
should not be subject to the same review
and approval of all other areas of the
county especially considering
the size of the dollars involved
so
they basically have had no public
budgeting
no oversight or transparency with the
delegation
if you carefully read this
obscure
enabling statute as amended
they don't have any borrowing power
themselves the gun stock area commission
has to get borrowing authority from the
delegation
and that whether it's a
revenue anticipation note
or a bond it has to be approved by a
super majority of the delegation
so there are bonds that are shown as
outstanding on the financial statement
of gun stock but they really are
obligations full faith and credit of the
taxpayers of belknap county
so
why would we why do people oppose this
this bill
the only reason that i can fathom is
they say we've had a good year
the management is great just leave us
alone and let us do our things
but what happens when it's not such a
good year
and if you look at you know their
questions for example if their budget
had been subject to review by the
delegation if you look in the footnotes
to the financial statements
you will see that there are three bond
issues outstanding
at various
two interest rates
four five percent two point seven eight
percent
three point five to four point three
percent but then if you look at the next
page which is page ten of the financials
you will see their capital leases and
capital leases are nothing more than a
substitute a way of borrowing
so you see that they have a bunch of
capital leases at varying interest rates
including
a 402
300 equipment lease
with interest at 11.8
percent
why a capital lease
and why not a bond
my answer is very simple if they had
asked for a bond for this they would
have had to make their presentation to
the delegation and they would have had
to have gotten approval from the
delegation so instead they went around
the delegation
signed a capital lease at almost 12
another example of
what we consider to be
just outrageous problems with the
finances at gun stock
is at the end of june or i'm sorry april
30th they had over six million dollars
in cash and current assets on hand after
the
ski season
in august
without a public hearing to discuss
bonuses
they paid bonuses over a hundred
thousand dollars
in cash bonuses
to some favored top people not the
people that are on the ski lifts
not the people that do the ski
instruction but top management
so we have a situation in which we have
a general manager
under contract with an annual base of a
hundred eighty four thousand dollars
plus benefits
and he got a forty thousand dollar cash
bonus
even without the cash bonus
he makes more than governor sununu
this is for running a ski resort in the
little town of guilford
so
what we're asking what my bill is asking
for and the sponsors
who are basically all from belknap
county
is that we
bring the gun stock budgeting process
into the same
controls and transparency that all other
aspects of county budgeting
experience
representative howard who is the chair
of the executive committee is here to
testify
he was the principal author of the last
amendment to the enabling legislation
he and i have discussed the bill and we
will probably be submitting an amendment
in a few days as soon as we can get
something out of ols
making a few minor technical corrections
but as it stands the bill the basic guts
of the bill will be the same which is
we want oversight by the delegation
there's an 18-member delegation elected
by the people the five-member
gun stock area commission is not elected
by the people they have terms longer
than two years they have five year terms
there is no accountability at present
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
how are the gun stock commissioners um
appointed five-year terms oh but house
they're staggered they're appointed by
the delegation okay by a majority vote
of the delegation the the enabling
statute says that the members are
appointed are subject to removal for
cause by the delegation
okay thank you follow-up okay
although this is kind of a separate
question but um
in the financial report you cited all of
the expenditures but i'm assuming gun
stock gets revenue as well right oh yes
so
except for a bad skier they're running
in the they run in the black this year
they this past year they ran yes
substantially in the black okay all
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so my understanding
that with under the
governance of the
any
county government you have governmental
activities and component units so my
understanding is that gun stock
ski area is a component unit are there
any other component units in beltmap
county
it is my understanding that other than
the 16
departments and functional areas i
listed on the one pager
and gun stock there are no other
county
um county operations that where the
county where the budget is either
determined by the gun stock delegate or
the belknap delegation or by some other
process like in this case by the gun
security commission i'm not i don't i'm
not aware of any other areas
it's the only area out of 16 areas that
is not under uh review by the lab
delegation
thank you representative silver for your
uh testimony um
the are there other ski areas that are
similar to gun stock
in the state of new hampshire
for instance cannon mountain
is i believe a state ski area
how does gun stock
compare to
cannon mountain and what is the
governance
the government how is cannon mountain
governed
as compared to gun stock
thank you representative for the
question i don't have an answer for you
because i don't have any statistics or
any research on those other areas the
only other ski area about which i have
some information
is like is the sunapee ski area which is
state-owned a state-owned property and
was operated by the state for a number
of years and ultimately was leased
and when it was leased
the operators then had to pay full real
estate taxes as opposed to being exempt
if you look carefully in the
in the enabling statute
it provides that
the
gun stock ski area pays real estate
taxes
of slightly less than seven thousand
dollars a year on a property that the
town of guilford's assessor says is
worth in excess of 15 million dollars
but if this were leased as sunapee is
sonope was originally not paying any
real estate taxes when they leased it to
a private operator there's an rsa that
says
you got to pay the full freight and so
they paid now hundreds of thousands of
dollars in real estate taxes i don't
know about cannon mountain or these
thank you
any other questions
representative
thank you mr chair um
thank you representative for taking my
question of itself
along the lines of representative los
alas
are there any other ski areas or
entertainment areas outdoor
entertainment areas
that are under either county
uh property or
county owned but operated like this
i don't i don't know the answer to that
sorry
any other questions for representative
thank you thank you mr chairman and
thank you for taking my my question i
know i'm hard to see over here but um i
just quickly was looking at this and
under the i think it's like basically
your first page it talks about
compensation is that compensation of
just the commissioners and that hundred
thousand dollar bonus you talked about
didn't go to commissioners correct it
went to it was over a hundred thousand
dollars and did not go to commission
none of it went to the commissioners it
went to 40 000 went to the general
manager and lesser amounts to the chief
financial officer
different different department heads
okay and those department heads are
chosen by the commissioners is that
correct i apologize for not asking for
follow-up sir
okay uh seeing no further questions
oh i'm sorry
representative matt
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative taking my letter i
appreciate you offering all this
information i'm curious
does the does the belknap
county commissioners review the audit
every year and follow up to that would
be
have there been um have there been
deficiencies noted in the management
letters for that for any of those audits
i have no idea whether the county
commission reviews the audit or not or
whether they do any follow-up it's not
under what i do know is it is does not
report to the to the delegation the
delegation does not is not asked to
review or comment or ask questions or
anything about it
and i'd like to emphasize you i don't
want to
you know
go beyond your question except
this is not a partisan issue
this is not a democrat issue or a
republican issue this is a taxpayer
issue
the money
in the coffers at gun stock belong to
the taxpayers of belmont county and if
if they don't if they accumulate money
and spend it on things that are not in
the best interests of the county
taxpayers that needs to stop
they need to
perhaps pay off the bonds early they
need to not try to circumvent the
bonding process by using capital leases
if this was under the control of the
delegation i can almost guarantee you
that the delegation would not have
thank you is there any oh yes
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question you said earlier that
the members of the commission were
appointed by the delegation correct is
that correct yes and that they could be
removed for cause yes is that correct
correct and that implies some level of
review by the delegation is that not
correct that that it does
for the delegation the authority to
remove for cause yes so
then follow up mr chair so
if you're removing someone for cause
then you must be reviewing that person's
performance to determine that there's
cause to remove them if there was a
preceding pending to remove someone that
would imply yes a review of their
performance a specification of charges
and due process
but you earlier said that the delegation
does not review the commissioner's
performance it has not yet reviewed the
specific performance of individual
commissioners
i
like to add one more thing and that is
that the gunstock area commission
several months ago actually filed a
lawsuit
in superior court against the delegation
seeking to enjoin the delegation
from exercising its removal power
set forth in the statute
and so far there have been two
proceedings one for a temporary
restraining order which was denied
one for a preliminary injunction which
was denied
and about an hour and a half ago the
motion for reconsideration by the
attorney for the gun security commission
to reconsider the denial of the
preliminary injunction
was
denied and the the last order judge
o'neil the superior court judge for that
area
said you're asking us the court to
enjoin the exercise of the removal power
granted to the delegation by the general
court
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
my taking my question
uh
during your testimony you mentioned that
there are years when the gun stock ski
area
is in the red and there's years when
they're in the black
when they're in the red
does
how do they clear that negative and when
they're in the black
when they
my understanding is when they have been
in the red in the past and it has been
sufficient that they couldn't pay their
bills as they fall do they'll do
that they actually
called on the delegation and the county
to pay their bond payments that were
required to be paid
when they have excess money like this
like this past year because it was a
good snow season and the covid
drove up the attendance they're they're
sitting on a lot of cash they have a lot
of cash they actually have proposed to
to
seek authorization for a revenue
anticipation loan while they're sitting
on millions of dollars of cash and i
think they saw that the handwriting was
on the wall they went through their
request
what they do with it is up to them
the statute says they give a percentage
of the gross to the county and what they
do with the rest is strictly up to them
yes representative
thank you mr chair just have a
different question
uh thank you for taking my uh question
representative
so
from your uh testimony i understand the
delegation still has
the
ability to appoint or remove the
commissioners and the delegation is
elected by the voters correct correct so
the delegation could change based on the
elections
so
you delegation still has the ability to
hold the commissioners
accountable
for
the performance of the gun stocker
isn't that indirectly done
indirectly yes representative that
indirectly that is the case however
every year
the county commission submits budget
proposals and are reviewed all these 16
areas every year
and we don't look to seek to remove any
individual head of a department or
anything like that for for overspending
or anything like that we we do hold the
county commissioners libel the county
commissioners we have a transfer policy
where the county commissioners must come
to the delegation for authority to
transfer between line items over a
certain amount and that was the subject
where the delegation actually in 2014
had to sue
the county commissioners and get an
injunction against the county
commissioners for violation
of the transfer policy
we have just discovered in our hearings
in the past week or 10 days
that they have ignored the provisions of
that injunction
and have overspent a line item without
an appropriation
which is
in our view which is going to probably
be referred to the attorney general's
office and perhaps the superior court
just to follow up to clarify i sit on
the hillsborough county executive
committee right as a and i'm also a
delegate from hillsborough county so i
understand the process of reviewing the
budget for the different departments and
my i'm trying to understand the
workings of the gun stock
and how its
commissioners are reviewing or they are
overseeing and the delegation has
the authority to
hold commissioners accountable so
indirectly through the commissioners the
delegation has the control over gun
stock am i correct
only the only control
is the
is the possibility of removal for cause
that is the only control it's not any
ability to
the gun stock area commission doesn't
report their budget to the delegation
doesn't ask for approval doesn't answer
questions about it it's
it's whatever its budget is and and the
process of removing a commissioner
is
extreme it is not something it's not as
bad it's not as difficult as impeachment
of a state official
but it is
it's pretty it's pretty a pretty drastic
remedy it's a pretty drastic remedy that
is yes so in yes the answer to your
question is yes indirectly there is some
control by virtue of its ability to
remove thank you
any other questions
yes representative thank you mr chairman
thank you uh for taking my question
representative
i i just had a chance to kind of look
this over i just got this before the
hearing began and
one of the things that
i'm wondering about is has there been
any market analysis
done of gun stock to its competitors
obviously it's competing with other ski
areas
um you know when you say it's you know
there's 16 departments in the in the uh
in the county but
i think operating a ski area is going to
be very different than operating a
nursing home there's a lot of
competition
and so i was wondering if there's ever
been a market analysis to see if the
financial practices of gun stock are
misaligned with what we might see among
their competitors particularly when you
mention the salary and bonuses
is that practice consistent with other
ski areas that gun stock is competing
with
i have not and i don't believe the
delegation is currently comprised has
seen any kind of market analysis or
market study
however
when belnap county issues bonds it has
to go to a rating service called moody's
to get a rating to sell their bonds the
last two times that
moody's then
issues a financial report to justify
supposedly their ratings
the last two
moody's reports which are online
available in the belknap county website
indicated the two major areas of
financial concern for the health of the
county finances
according to moody's
was the nursing home
and gun stock
but i have not seen
gunstock has for the commissioners have
proposed the rough outlines of a
so-called master plan for future
development without any numbers without
any you know
analysis or any detailed discussion
provided to the delegation because in
order to do any kind of master plan
they're going to almost certainly have
to issue bonds and they need to come to
the delegation for that we have not seen
any numbers we have not seen any kind of
market study anything like that the
answer is no all right thank you
i'm sorry it's davis representative
davis
thank you mr chair
uh does the county delegation oversee
the nursing home expenditures yes and
yet they are a concern to moody's as
well yes
is there a reason why they are a concern
to moody's yes because
the cause
of difficulty in staffing and the
staffing difficulty
predate covet
they the nursing home has 90-something
beds there's 60-something beds presently
occupied because they can't get enough
staff and they've got a waiting list of
people if they had the staff
and if the cms the federal cms
rules go into effect requiring the
nurses and all the staff on the site to
be fully vaccinated
there
according to the nursing home
administrator testifying last week to
the delegation
they would have enough people to staff
16 beds
out of a 90 plus follow up mr chair yes
why has the delegation allowed the
nursing home to come
to be continuing cause of concern for
moody's
we
keep asking questions of the nursing
home administrator
and basically everything we're told is
we've got mandates from the federal
government we've got mandates from the
state government we've got this mandate
and this regulation and that regulation
and we simply do not get enough money to
run the nursing home when i was on the
delegation in 2017
and going through the budget process i
asked the nursing uh the nursing
administrator how much and the county
administrator how much out of pocket
does belknap county taxpayers go
after you pull in the medicare medicaid
private pay and all that stuff what's
the net out of pocket to
that
belknap county taxpayers have to pay in
2017 it was 500 000
this year it's over a million dollars
reimbursement rates change
um
you know all
there have been there have been all
sorts of answers proposals things like
that
i don't have the easy answer to the
nursing home problem
i don't know that anybody does okay i'm
going to go now oh representative
right after you uh
jim i'm going to go to the audience for
some input
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking another question i'll go as
quickly as i can i'm reading through
this quickly and i see in your bill
the the attempt to uh amend 399.14 and i
looked real quickly at the other bills
which went to 399.14 and 399.15
but i'm looking at 399.17
and i'll read real quickly it says i'm
summarizing the billnap cap belknap
county commissioner shall be relieved of
all duties and responsibilities with
respect to the operation and maintenance
of this area i'm just curious why that
piece wasn't
considered to be struck or amended
because it seems to me that with that
remaining that this would be in conflict
am i missing something i don't believe
that the county commissioners since we
basically if we put the county
commissioners take that out put the
county commissioners over
the gun stock area delegation or the gun
security commission
you basically have duplicated two
supervisory jurisdictions where all
we're seeking to do here
is to bring the budgetary process we're
not looking to micromanage the
day-to-day operation we don't want to
say you do this and you do that what
we're saying is bring us the proposed
budget
let us ask the questions and we don't
have to be experts we're not experts in
the sheriff's department we're not
experts in the nursing and we're not
experts in all these different
departments we get educated by the
department heads and we make adjustments
that we think are appropriate for the
taxpayers
we didn't didn't focus on that quite
frankly on that issue all we're
interested in is the finances and
transparency
thank you and as i indicated we're going
to ray howard and i are going to be
probably submitting a
technical corrections amendment there's
some some little tweaks to some of the
technical aspects of of the bill which
we'll probably be submitting to the
committee later this week but not the
bot the body of the bill is this is
essentially the same fyi we'll be
exacting this bill probably about a week
and a half
we'll have it before then
okay at this point i'm going to go to
those of you in the audience
and i'm going to call by the way
we have indications of five people who
indicated they support this bill and we
have
uh additional indication that somewhere
north of 1200 oppose the bill that have
provided input to us as i said
it's a very well orchestrated and
finance campaign
opposition okay next i'd like to hear
and thank you representative
pull the microphone in front of you
please
hello my name is rusty mcclear
i am from meredith new hampshire i've
lived there for 51 years
i'm in the hospitality business and have
been for
almost all of my life
uh i've sold
or owned a
hotel in new hampshire called mill falls
at the lake it's a 171 room hotel
i sold it in 2018.
uh
it had
the hotel was comprised of four large
buildings 300 employees four restaurants
171 rooms
they're all in meredith and generated a
revenue of 21 million
a year and
for the last few years
and when it sold it sold for 55 million
my other major efforts are aimed at
restaurant development
i.e the common man roadside which is
currently currently consists of the
common man roadside
route 93 in hooksett which consists of
two 40 000 square foot buildings one on
each side of the road with sales of
about 26 million
and a value of 60 million
plus i am an
applicant to build a similar facility on
route 95 at hampton this project will
con consist of
two
40 000 square foot buildings
with a 60 million dollar
revenue
projection and a 75 million dollar value
we are also working on a chain of
restaurants
uh in the state and northern new england
with uh 5 000 square foot restaurants we
have three that are built in the state
now and these restaurants are to travel
the public ways
but not major highways not interstates
we currently have three of them open in
the state of new hampshire with a value
of 15 million
i say all this because i want
you to be aware all of you
to be aware that between
and i'm sure you'll be calling garrett
kadesh
between gary kadesh and myself our
breadth of hot hospitality experience is
extensive
gary has done a stellar job of bringing
in quality management i didn't notice
who was actually here
there he is
tom day
who ran waterville valley for
30 years i've known him for that 30
so
gary has done a stellar job of bringing
quality management
and they are
executing their plan exceptionally well
gun stock is now on a terrific path it
hasn't always been i there was
some statements about you know it's been
it has never
been as good as it is now never been as
good as it was last year
this year is better than last year last
year was a record year
gunstock is now in a terrific
path we don't want to let them ruin it
and frankly i think they are trying to
ruin it
one of them wants to in reality he wants
to lease this the area he's made those
statements he's made them in public so
they're in the press
he simply wants to get rid of the ski
area
that's not what most of us in the area
want
we like having our own ski area there
it's profitable when it's run well
it's
frankly it can be very profitable and we
have a plan to make it very profitable
and i have built a number of
properties that are or were very
profitable
gary has done the same thing
we can do it again here
thank you thank you questions for the uh
yes
representative
thank you mr chair thank you mr mcclear
this uh
for your testimony
um
you have done a great job yes and my
question to you is
you are looking at gun stock commission
as doing a private entity that's
or independently operated entity that's
supposed to do what it's supposed to do
for our state correct
and
you being in the business are saying
this is run well done well
let that happen so that
our state can shine as a destination
that is
true to a degree i i believe
because i had 300 employees at the hotel
i had 300 employers at uh
at 93 i'll have 400 employees at 95.
you know we'll have 2 000 employees
probably the time we get done i believe
that there has to be oversight
but the management does the oversight
and the management knows what to look
for and they know what to do
follow one follow up
so in your
testimony you're alluding to that it's a
well run
and with the supervision you're not
saying to not have the supervision but
let the
management take its course that they're
doing that are doing something well let
the people who know what they're doing
and what to do
that's really all we're looking for and
some of the things that have been said
about the nursing home
that's one of the reasons we don't want
this to happen they're not they don't
know how to run a nursing home and
they're not running it well
and they're gonna they're asking you to
let them take over gun stock they admit
they don't know how to run it and they
won't run it well
yes
hi um just could you spell your name for
uh note-taking purposes for us real
quick sure m c
capital l e a r is my last name my first
name is edward
and my real name is rusty
okay thanks
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so um you mentioned in your testimony
um the idea that
someone or a group of people are
interested in either privatizing gun
stock or leasing it could you explain
what that process would be in order to
enact that
what would that process look like my
understanding and i have never my
understanding and i've never read the
1959 document i believe gary has
and maybe tom has
i believe that's open
to allow the gun stock commissioners
to lease and or sell
right now nobody on the commission
in gun stock or as far as the thousands
of people who have
joined this effort and it is thousands
uh want to see at least or sold
and
the gentleman who is sitting here prior
to this does want to see at least
we believe we have we believe we have
very good management
and have
senior management who can look towards
the future and say this is what should
be done with us
follow-up mr chair okay so to be clear
that your answer to my question um who
would
ultimately make that decision your
answer is that
the gun stock commissioners
would make the decision whether or not
to lease or privatize gun stock
the gun stock commissioners will be the
ones who will put the plan together
thank you um yes representative yes
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um i've enjoyed many of your properties
so thank you uh when looking over the
financial statement would you in your in
your opinion as a businessman regard it
as being competitive or
uh more successful that within its its
market
this this past year
or last year it was very competitive it
was
the best year ever out of whatever it is
65 years or something like that so it's
it has
been
changed into a tremendously competitive
and successful and profitable piece of
property prior to this it was up and
down
the margins were too thin
and just about everything
and we have a very professional
accountant on the staff
who tells us when we're going in the
wrong way and she tells us in no
uncertain terms when we're going in the
wrong way
and uh tom day is
i hate to say this in front of them but
they're he's as good as you can get
and
he knows how to run a ski area like i
say he ran waterville valley for years
and we have some other really first-rate
people there and i had something in here
i say this to you because i want to be
aware that garrick today kardashian
myself our breadth of hospitality
experience is extensive gary has done a
stellar job of bringing quality
management and they are executing the
plan exceptionally well
gary
gunstock is now on a terrific
path don't let them ruin it it's on i
really
excuse me
don't let them ruin it i guess that's it
yes
my last question is uh i notice on the
statement that there's uh payments to
the county of 247 thousand four hundred
dollars last year um how would would can
you tell me more about what those
payments to the county are
payments of the county i believe are 1.7
1.75 okay thank you
all right uh seeing no other questions
uh
mr mcclear thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
next we're going to call on
mr posner feels please feel free to use
the wipes to wipe the microphone before
i'm good thank you very much
um
i'm here as a i'm here as a skier
i'm here as a retired businessman and
executive
and i'm here as someone who does not
like political game playing
last fall
someone showed me this bill
and at the time i was not aware of the
let's call it the interesting dynamic
between the commission and the
delegation
and i read the bill and i said what the
heck is this this makes no sense at all
no sense
there are many theories about running
businesses
new ones come along every year you could
cover all of these tables with the books
that come out citing new theories new
gimmicks new miracle cures for the
world's business problems you probably
all have some of them on your coffee
tables let me tell you not a single one
of them advocates taking financial
control away from the board of directors
and of course the area commission
is the board
taking financial control away from the
boards of directors are typically
empowered to take full responsibility
for running a business
and they're measured by results
that works
as mr silber correctly said they set
their budget in their own way
with no public budgeting they're
accountable for their results
imagine this conversation
between robert kraft and bill
bill
i'd like to talk to you about your
playbook
from now on it will need my approval
not just upfront but all the changes
along the way
even during games
how do you think that would go over
it would be seismic
so much for business theory let's take a
look at gunstock
when i first skied here there were a
bunch of t-bars and even that cute
single chair that some of you may
remember from 1938
today look at the place
it's a competitive four season resort
and that evolution did not just happen
it was brought about by 60 plus years of
good management and
decades of commissioners
it's fiscally stable
it's profitable it's popular and it's
having its best years in history as as
you have already heard this morning
that business model is working
so you might ask
what really is the agenda of the bill's
sponsors
do they have a formula to make gun stock
work even better
i doubt that very much
do they want to take over because they
know so much about ski area management
hardly
are they worried that gun stock is a
drain on the taxpayer
not exactly it does not cause belknap's
taxpayers a dime and as you've heard
last year they had a record profits and
passed a quarter of a million dollars
over to the county
representative silver says gun stock
should be accountable to the taxpayers
in the same way as other county
operations
that
i ask you to
uh in your continued testimony to
be careful about calling out individuals
and
rendering
disparaging information about them i i
think you can make your point without
that okay i was actually quoting
something i read in the paper but that
that's fine so it's it's been emphasized
the sponsors of the bill
really want uh gunstock to be a de facto
department of the county they want to
control it like the nursing home where
the oxygen budget was cut they won't
approve competitive wages and as a
result the nursing home is short staffed
where quality of service is not part of
the equation it's all about cutting
taxes
the 1959 enabling act was designed
expressly to keep gunstock's operation
independent of government and politics
so it could be professionally managed
like any business enterprise
and that's worked pretty well for 62
years
in my view this is nothing but a
transparent effort to the
enabling act so that gunstock will
become a de facto county department so
why not just be honest and sponsor a
in the interests of good government good
business and plain old yankee common
sense i urge you to vote no on this
reckless bill
thank you thank you are there any
questions
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
in your
is it
i'm trying to phrase it in a form of
question
so um
would you believe that this is a
well-run private enterprise with a
partnership with the public which is it
pays back to the ratepayers of belknap
county absolutely and so
well it's making the positive
impact or in the right direction
as a taxpayer or as a businessman you
want to make sure that you oppose this
because it's going to disrupt the
progress
absolutely i think there's a point where
you have to let managers manage
so would you consider this as a good
public private partnership that's
working well for our state extremely
well thank you
uh
okay i would uh
at this point like the carrot call on uh
gary
katiscal can i help you go ahead
how do you pronounce the last name it's
key dash k dash thank you and uh
mr k dash uh giving the time of the day
i just ask you to do whatever you can to
to tighten up your comments um
yes thank you uh
chairman and thank you for the
opportunity to speak i i actually was
hoping to ask for some extra time to
respond to some testimony given by
uh
the
by i guess i'm not supposed to mention
his name but
the sponsor of this bill
and perhaps to correct some of the
points that i believe he's misleading
this group and would like to do that
but let me let me quickly go through my
my prepared comments and then hopefully
have time to address that or we can have
that come through during the questions
my name is gary kadash i'm vice chairman
of the gun stock area commission i was
chairman for the last 18 months and
transitioned through the
for the rolling process of chairman
amongst the five commissioners
i come before you today
well qualified as an accomplished and
experienced business leader to testify
strongly in opposition of house bill
1078.
i feel i must
qualify my remarks by for 40 for 30
years plus i have served as a chief
executive officer of six companies both
public and private to include igloo
coolers i'm sure you have have many of
them the coleman company you might have
one of their lanterns
bauer hockey your kids might skate bole
eyewear stow mountain resort which is
very relevant to what we're talking
about here today and the head ski
company
i've served successfully on many public
and private board of directors that
includes purple innovation tender
corporation up in littleton new
hampshire
and
the u.s ski team foundation the new
hampshire sweepstakes commission and
stare chairman and state chairman of the
united states olympic committee national
ski area association director among many
others
in addition i also was appointed by
governor john sununu back in the 80s to
study the canon canon sunopee
properties and i was part of the the
decisions that were made there and the
decisions were to hold on to them at
that time over 20 years ago
i've been recognized globally as a
leader that gathers talent around a
vision and a team that produces
extraordinary results and i was honored
to receive the ernst young ceo of the
year award for transforming eagle
coolers from an underperforming 67 year
old brand to best in class
belmont county delegation appointed me
to the gac three plus years ago by a
vote of fourteen to one
because i assured the delegation it
could be run as a su as a
self-sustaining business
for the past two years gun stock has
done just that it's operated one hundred
percent independently not needing a
seasonal bridge loan known as a revenue
anticipation note which has to be
required by by the county
that's because we generated enough
income to pay for the expenses which was
previously represented to equally
slightly above the nursing home
that's quite a miscarriage the nursing
home doesn't have income the nursing
home gets gets funded by taxes gunstock
mountain resort has no
mechanism or resources coming from
taxpayers it is a hundred percent
independent it generates its income from
paying customers who are willing to come
and pay for their goods goods and
services
i'm going to defer to
our cfo kathy white who will report
today and testify to take you through
gun stock's strong financial performance
and relative to a comment earlier there
are multiple petitions circulating with
over three thousand signatures opposing
actions to include house bill 1078 it's
not just a well-organized
mechanism it's the public speaking it's
a public saying what they want
and the delegation is not listening and
that is terrifying to think that they
could gain control of the operations
through the budget control if you
contain the control the budget you
control the business
there's no other way to do it
gun stock mountain resort is a treasured
gem
it was developed in the 1930s by the u.s
government works works progress
administration program called the wpa as
was stole so vermont cannon mountain and
others around the country
the first ski lift in new hampshire was
built by the wpa on today's gun stock
mountain in 1936 and 30 37 and
recreation has been offered there
successfully every year was since with
multiple olympic champions representing
new hampshire coming from our slopes and
ski jumps this is a big sense of pride
this is something we should all protect
like a child
in 1959 the state of new hampshire gave
gunstock mountain resort to the citizens
of belknap county and legislated into
law the 1959 enabling act which
established the gun stock area
commission
the law gave responsibility and
authority to the gac to operate gunstock
as an enterprise of belknap county
the gac consists of five rotating
experienced business county leaders like
myself and rusty mcclear who functioned
as a board of directors and was given
broad powers to operate develop and
and
to operate and develop the recreation
area and has been doing so successfully
since 1959
gac was established with a clear purpose
at that time and if you go back in the
history you'll see this in writings to
get politics out of gun stock
i have with me a letter headlined
budgetary control
must remain
must remain with gun stock commission
it's from 16 former gac commissioners
representing collectively 150 years of
service to gun stock mountain mountain
resort the letter represents strong
opposition to house bill 1078 and should
be noted by this committee and i will
leave you with with copies of it i
appreciate you considering
those
prior commissioners while there is a
dispute between the key sponsors of
house bill 1078 and the gac as to what
gun stock is
and how it should be run i can assure
you gun stock is a business in every
definition and must be managed
accordingly not like a government
department
gmr and i'm repeating gmr genera
generates gunshot wound resorts or
generates a hundred percent of its
revenue from customers who freely choose
to buy gun stocks goods and services
unlike the nursing home there are no
federal local or taxpayer funds that go
to support gun stock
conversely gun stock pays belknap county
1.75 percent of its gross revenue
247 thousand dollars in 2021 and with
all other funds going to pay for goods
and services care and maintenance and
the very important practice of
establishing reserves to pay for future
capital improvements in order to sustain
and maintain the property
because gun stock is a business it must
operate like a business to compete and
thrive you asked a question earlier
about how does it compare to weather
survive time i'd be happy to share that
with you because i have a lot of
knowledge about that we work with a
long-range plan and an annual operating
plan from which a yearly budget and
capital plan is established
management prepares the budget and after
careful consideration by the gac
approves and monitors it
because there are many uncontrollable
variables that present themselves during
business
year
during business years such as weather
equipment failures the area needs to be
able to adjust and move funds from
various departments while keeping within
the guardrails of the budget in order to
keep the business running
imagine
a breakdown of a lift on christmas week
martin luther king weekend february
vacation we make money in 16 weeks of
the year and we have to go to the
delegation and ask them for approval to
move 300
from snow making to a lift
that is what that is what's being asked
and if you approve this bill that is
what will be will be subjected to and i
as an experienced business manager an
executive and ski area operator can
assure you that will put gun suck
the county delegation and chair of
observe
gun stock meetings
and there's only one meeting that i know
of in the last three years that i've
been on the commission
that either the chair or the vice chair
of the belknap county commission did not
sit in and monitor
we ask them to sit at our table
they they refuse
we ask them if they have any questions
i don't know why they don't ask maybe
they don't understand them
but they don't ask there are multiple
opportunities for them to have this
review
every single month and you're going to
hear from our cfo
and you're going to see the level of
departmental breakdown and financial
controls that we have
they get to look at that that is an
oversight that is more than i've ever
seen in any of the companies that i'm on
i'm going to skip here a little bit
about
i had to say about the nursing nursing
home but
i want to call your attention
to an article written by ms sullivan and
published in the new hampshire business
journal union leader and laconia daily
sun
headlined headache for gun stock
employees i have a copy of that several
copies of them here i would encourage
you to read that article you may have
already seen it it really frames
in an unbiased way what is going on
and what the employees of gun stock
mountain resort are dealing with and
what what the
if you gac
copies of that could you provide it to
us
i will provide them i have copies i
don't think i have enough for all of you
but just give one to the clerk okay
um i will also provide copies of um the
letter from the gac
for former uh commissioners
with my professional experience and
opinion if house bill 1078 is voted into
law it will have long lasting undue
consequences and hobbled
the continued successful operation of
gunstock mountain resort and i will tell
you it is
incredibly
disingenuous for anybody to say that the
only reason gun stock was successful
last year was because of covet
please
think about what it took to run that
operation and keep the employees safe
and our customers safe and the
incremental expense of cleaning that
those buildings and the loss of our food
and beverage revenue and still be able
to do that
that is the most insulting thing i have
ever seen and that's what the headaches
come from you can't turn the turn this
if that
happens it will be relegated relocating
gun stock to a position of
non-competitiveness possible failure
like the missteps of many former new
hampshire ski areas we need to get
politics out of gun stock mountain
resort it was taken out in 1959 and that
was the intent of the 1959 uh enabling
act
the gac
voted majority voted on
after
november 17 2001 meeting to oppose house
bill 1078 and i asked the committee here
to do likewise and a vote against this
bill
now i scribbled some quick notes um
and i heard
earlier testimony that a few years ago
the county had to make up for
a failed financial matter and payout
paid off that was 20 years ago
it was the only time we know of that it
happened
and the county
and gun stock
put together a plan to pay it off and
we've been willing way at it
um
we're not a taxpayer
we pay 247 thousand dollars to the
county
take a look at what waterville valley
pays to waterville take a look at what
loon ski area plays to
the town of lincoln
they do not pay 247 000 so don't paint
us as a group that do not uh pay taxes
and as for bonuses
we got to be very clear here
i sit as i mentioned earlier i sit on on
a lot of boards in fact i sit on the
compensation committee of purple
innovation which is a 1.6 billion dollar
corporation i also sit on the audit
committee of that board
and one of the most important things is
attracting people together talent and
retaining them
i
i can present to you and if you i don't
have it here with me because i didn't
think this was going to come up but i
can present to you from the executive
recruiter firm that hired helped us
identify tom day
their analysis of compensation
throughout the industry in new hampshire
in new england in the midwest and the
west coast it was very comprehensive and
tom day's compensation i shouldn't be
saying this in front of him
his base of 180 is below market
we knew that and we put in his contract
that we would establish a long-term
incentive plan
but when they turned the business so
successful last year and worked so hard
at it and we had money way over what the
budget was supposed to be
brian gallagher and myself as vice chair
went to ray howard and mike sylvia
privately and said
we think we're thinking about paying
bonuses what do you think
nobody set off red lights nobody sent
yellow lights nobody jumped up and down
and said nothing
just sort of said okay
and so
as we finish the year and as the audit
added audit produced evidence that we
could pay the bonuses and the bonuses
are not out of taxpayers money it would
is paid in excess money that they made
over and above this year's annual budget
mr kadish uh
i'd like to hear from mr tom day would
you consider your building he's in the
building he's he
he's here to testify today are you in
the audience he's right here uh so if
you would consider yielding to him we
would we would yeah i just want to make
one last
one last competent comment
the
so i covered the market analysis um
please don't compare gunstock mountain
resort
to
the sheriff's department
or
the the belknap county
uh
nursing home
they are funded by tax to payer dollars
gun stock does not get funded by
taxpayer dollars it's well run
we have excellent management there
we've put together extraordinary plans
and it will continue to operate well
provided you allow us to do that thank
you
and i can take questions if you like
thank you mr kadesh from
meredith from meredith yes uh does
anybody have any questions
representative
yes thank you mr chair thank you mr um
for taking my question so in
gun stock is
well run on the right track and a jewel
for the industry in our state which is a
tourism and an entertainment
yes it is yes it is i'll go one step
further i believe it is best in class in
the state of new hampshire by a country
mile and you can read an article that
was in the in the journal
a couple of weeks ago about the failures
of bales management of their resorts in
new hampshire
one quick follow-up mr chair
do you have statistics about how many
olympians or how many skiers that gun
stock trained from new hampshire to send
to the world
i'm sorry i didn't understand the
question i said do you have statistics
or i'm sure you have numbers of how many
skiers
and
athletes that gunstock trained from new
hampshire to represent new hampshire in
the world
ski
yeah i think if i understand your
question right you want to know how many
people come to gun stock compared to
others no just how many you have key
stars
that athletes that trained in gun stock
oh i'm sorry pardon me
um i don't have that off the top of my
head obviously penny patoo um heidi prus
who is a candidate to join the
commission which we the the commission
really hopes that she gets there um
and there was a jumper um a norwegian
jumper um who came here and went to the
olympics and unfortunately was killed in
world war ii
but there are numerous athletes who
compete in the world cup um and we're
well represented by these people
thank you
yes uh representative gallagher
yeah um my question because i just get
the spelling of your
last name real quick for note-taking
purposes
yeah
k-i-e-like edward
d-a-i-s-c-h
thank you very much okay thanks
thank you for your time we appreciate
your testimony thank you
next uh we'll hear from tom day from
guilford
and mr day i think uh
you'll notice that the time is escaping
us rapidly so i'd ask you
we certainly want to hear what you have
to say but please uh
keep it tight as you can
uh yes thanks very much for listening to
me today i'll be brief i'm i'm generally
pretty brief whenever i'm
getting into some situation like this uh
just a little bit about my background i
started um working at waterville valley
in 1978 as a lift attendant i retired
from there in 2010 as the vice president
general manager i've had a lot of
experience in other businesses i don't
need to go through that
um and
in the in the meantime i started i also
worked for mountain guard insurance
which is a major insurer of the ski
business and i worked for them for five
years and i in the process of that time
i traveled throughout the country
inspecting ski areas and talking with
the management at ski areas i did about
40 skiers at that time i'm also on the
board of directors of ski new hampshire
and i have been i'm also a recipient of
the bill whitney award for exceptional
leadership in the ski business that ski
new hampshire
gives out so all the gm's a lot of the
gm's in the ski business are on the ski
new hampshire board
so um
i started working in january 15th 2020
at gunstock and uh it's been an
exceptionally good experience for me
the ski area is of gem as they said in
belknap county there's a lot of great
people that work there that have helped
us get to the spot that we needed to be
and one of the things that i think is
important to understand is that the gun
stock area commission doing businesses
gun stock mountain resort is a business
owned by belknap county we generate all
the cash to sustain the operation we
receive no money from the county or any
of the taxpayers of belknap county
it's extremely important to the success
of gun stock that is allowed to continue
operating as a business managed by a
senior team of professionals with
guidance provided by the gunstock area
commission and one of the things i know
there's a lot of comparisons to the
nursing home and this and that and you
know the whole politics of what what
what goes on is is something that i'm
i'm
becoming exposed to or was never aware
of before i'm here i came here because
they the former gm retired and they
wanted someone to come in here and run
the business run it as a business and be
able to get us some good um
financial achievements which which we've
done i do as we echo gary's um sentiment
when we talk about the fact that the
reason that we did well was because of
covin that's just
that's sp spoken by someone that doesn't
understand running a ski business at all
so that's that was ridiculous it was a
very difficult year we did well we did a
lot of adjusting and that's the thing
that is concerns me most about this
house bill you really have to adjust in
the ski business as gary said you have
16 weeks to make money you have to
adjust everything you do we've got five
lifts we've got 13 compressor 13 pumps
in our snow making building with three
compressors we have five cats that groom
225 acres and no matter how much you
plan
in the summers no matter what your plan
is in the winters things go wrong and
when something goes wrong with one of
these pieces of equipment you have to
respond immediately i'll get a call at
2am and say we just lost a pump in the
compressor house which means that our
snowmaking capacity is going to be down
by 25 or 50 percent my question is do
you have it out yet and is it on a truck
going somewhere to get repaired because
you have no time to be able to make a
decision that you have to go talk to
somebody i would call the commit
chairman of the commission the gun stock
area commission and say hey look we lost
a pump or we lost a gearbox and a lift
it's out and it's on its way and they
say great let us know how it's going
we don't sometimes even have it we have
a general idea what that's going to cost
but we don't have time to be able to go
and ask a delegation uh that
i don't understand the process i
understand it could be seven days before
they could call a meeting to have that
type of answer we can't afford to have
something like that happen we got we're
moving we're moving machine we have 51
pieces of rolling stock those are things
with motors in them that keep things
rolling here we have a campsite with 300
spots in it so
there's
there's so many things that we have to
do quickly and you know what
i'm really good at it i was an
operations manager at waterville before
i became the general manager i know
about all the operations at the resort i
understand how we do it we've got a
great staff for people that do it but
you know equipment failures is part of
running the ski area and you got to be
able to work fast and you've got to be
able to get it done because you don't
have time to wait because if you get
into a situation where you're out with a
pump and your snowmaking system is down
or you have a lift that's down for a
number of days
people notice that it's especially now
in in the world of social media you can
get vilified and crucified in that
situation like that because you're not
doing what you need to do we have a lift
that goes down we had we lost an
emergency brake in one of our main lifts
at the top we had to go get it rebuilt
in littleton we stayed all night to pull
it out we brought it up in littleton we
put it back in we got it running the
next day
people were very annoyed that it was
down a day
so we need to be able to take a look at
this operation and understand that the
18 delegates
don't know what it takes to run a skier
and we can't take time to be able to go
and go to them and say
um you know by the way we have a problem
and we need to get it fixed or i've
already taken it there and we budget for
repairs but we don't budget for major
repairs
and we've done an incredible job great
job running this business myself our
senior staff
all the other managers that are there
and one other thing to mention that
wasn't brought up was we did incentivize
our managers the 16 managers they also
got uh compensated at the uh at the
beginning in fact we
we accrued money for them we didn't
accrue money for ourselves because we
only get rewarded if we beat budget and
we beat it by a million dollars last
year so
i you know i can close this with with
this thing it's it's a time sensitive
business we can't have 18 people that
don't know anything about the business
trying to tell us how we have to work it
so you know the old saying is it ain't
broke don't fix it well my saying is
is that
if it if it
if it's running well it's demonstrated
by our revenues you guys can look at the
financials don't try to change it
because that's going to be a problem for
us and and we can run this business we
can run it successfully there was a
point brought up about like i said money
that was owed it was 20 years ago i'm
not that familiar with it but we've
since paid down a lot of bonds we're
doing a great job we've put a master
plan together to be able to continue to
to develop the resort and be able to be
competitive in the marketplace um it's a
great spot it's a beautiful place if
you've never been there it's exceptional
and uh we've got a lot of loyal skiers
and riders that have written and
participated in their displeasure with
what potentially could happen so i would
strongly oppose uh house bill 1078.
thank you yes representative
thank you mr
thank you well
mr dave for taking my question
so i'm just going back to your best year
that you did it was under a global
pandemic
so what was your key to success in terms
of
best practices in business and
especially in a ski
would you say that
you put all your
talent and your team together
and that was your key to success
and was that any duplications yes i mean
we were in november when we realized
well first off i started working january
15th of 2020 and march 15th of 2020
everything shut down because of covin
we had to make a decision to furlough 35
of our 65 full-time employees um and and
cut back all our summer operations
because we knew we couldn't generate the
revenue that we needed to and we
couldn't safely operate with the um best
safe of our safety of our staff and of
of our
of the guests so then when we rolled
into november we were like oh my gosh
you can't load a quad lift with four
people you can't have people that aren't
riding in the same party coming together
you can't you can have 50 less people in
the base lodge for food and reference
revenue so we were like
we've got to make a bunch of changes so
we did we took we got two food trucks in
the parking lot and that that took we
lost two five hundred thousand dollars
in food and beverage we made two hundred
thousand dollars on that by doing that
we adjusted the way that we loaded the
list we adjusted the way we ran our bus
systems we stopped taking people to
remote lots we made people reserve
tickets online which made us understand
what our controls were
we we had to spend we spent over 150 000
and just setting up the way to clean and
safely sanitize everything to make sure
our staff and guests were safe we
constantly ran around trying to adjust
every day i was also on the
committee for the reopening of the ski
areas with the state of new hampshire i
was the chair of that so that we could
go and speak with the governor and the
opening committees and talk about how we
can make it work for us so we
we that's the thing with this business
you don't you don't make a plan and you
start at the beginning of the winter you
make a plan and every day
you have to figure out something else
because something's going wrong that
year we absolutely adjusted everything
we did every day to make it work and we
ended up having a successful season and
yes people were skiing mid-week because
they were able to work remotely from
home but then again we found out that we
converted so many people that seem to
enjoy what gun stock was that our season
pass sales are up 30 this year and we
are going to have in a non-covered year
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my
question kind of commenty um
you you said that you have you had to do
all these adjustments because of covid
um would it be fair to say that you're
doing adjustments constantly because you
really don't know what level of snow
we're going to get and how much you're
going to be able to make and when the
warm weather is going to come the cold
weather or so on so aren't you kind of
at the
every year making adjustments maybe
covered with more extreme but
yes i mean it's it's a it's
you know it's a tough business when
mother nature's your boss but you have
to be able to adjust every way you can
we have we have colored days red blue
yellow and green so green blue yellow
red that we adjust our staff levels
prior on a thursday we have a meeting we
look at what we think our budgeted
numbers will be if for some reason the
weatherman said it's going to be
10 below zero or snowing on a saturday
we know we're not going to get the
people we should we adjust our staffing
levels accordingly so it's a like like
gary said it's 16 weeks to make money
you can't miss a day we have a daily
sales and labor report every day
they get we get a report that all of our
staff managers and senior managers get
that shows you what the revenue was from
the day before and what the expenses
were from the day before by department
because you can't wait till the end of
the week
to take a look at what happened because
it's too late
thank you representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question with regard to the
language the the
added language in the bill
referencing a supplemental appropriation
needing to be approved by the county
convention do you have any sense as to
what the timeline or how long that would
take
if you had a supplemental
appropriation that needed to be approved
beyond
the budget that was approved
have you gotten any spoken to anybody
to get a sense and an understanding as
well i've
it seems like there's a little bit of a
moving target on that so i can't answer
that totally it doesn't seem like
anything could be
the way it is now where
if we have to move
if um if we have to go and like i said
have a catastrophic failure where we're
going to spend 30 50 000 on something we
can go do it i don't think we could with
that but i don't know because once again
there's there's a lot of discussion
about it i'm not sure i understand
it all other than it seems like there is
more
unneeded oversight
to to delay the opportunities that we
have to be able to make adjustments to
our business that is really makes a
difference because if you start getting
a bad rap and social media about lifts
not running and snow making not being
done because we've got a breakdown that
we can't repair you lose customers and
after a while you lose them permanently
okay thank you mr day from uh
guilford
appreciate your testimony and we're
going to hear next from catherine white
also from
guilford and catherine i'm going to ask
you the same thing i've asked the others
to see if you can limit your testimony
with still getting your point across
absolutely
so i'm just going to read
so my name is katherine white i am the
chief financial officer at gun stock
area commission
dba
gun stock mountain resort and i just
want to focus on
that dba doing business as so we are
running gun stock area commission as a
business
i've been in the accounting profession
for over 30 years i have been employed
at gun stock since 2018.
i've got experience both in public and
private sector i hold a bachelor of
science degree in accounting and a
master's of science degree in accounting
gun stock is a business
it derives its cash from revenue not
from an allocation of tax monies
collected by the residents of belnap
county
it is imperative to the success of gun
stock that is allowed to continue
operating as a business managed by a
senior team of professionals with
oversight provided by the gunstock area
commission
gun stock is a complex business we have
19 departments and we manage over 500
general ledger accounts
unlike any government agency these
expenses
a majority of the expenses are variable
not fixed
in addition these expenses have a direct
correlation to revenue so
to just explain that as our revenue
increases we have to spend more money
that was not in the budget we have
increased labor
increase cost of goods so delaying those
decisions
when revenue is growing today and we
need to spend cost of goods and labor to
capture those revenues
we are a business and we need to make
those decisions daily
uh frequently frequently expenses need
to be flexed in response to those daily
changes in revenue and unforeseen
circumstances any delay in those
decisions will have immediate and
long-term negative financial
ramifications
as tom day had stated we look at daily
sales
daily labor
daily so we can flex
every expenditure that we need to make
to ensure
we're capturing revenue
the senior management team presents the
operating plan and budget to the gun
stock area commissions we review key
metrics benchmarking capital
expenditures
debt ratios and cash flow and again
unlike
the shares department we operate
strictly on cash flow
we do not operate our business on
approved
budget expenditures our business is run
on cash flow that means
in a year
off our budget we know what we're going
to have available for cash and based on
that cash
we make decisions so we flex those
decisions to either
increase business decrease business
close summer operations because of covid
where we afraid we we ran the numbers
that we would lose more money than
making so this is not a static operation
that your budget set
we move on we're changing daily we run
off of cash flow so we don't get any ppa
money we don't get any government money
we don't get anything from the county
we did in fact in 22 years ago we did
have the county step in and take over
some of our bonds but again that was 22
years ago
since then we have gone to the
delegation and received approval for
over 10 million dollars in additional
bonds since that 2000 that was money
spent to generate revenue
summer attractions repairs maintenance
on a few various things
we paid those bonds back we have made
payments to those bonds
out of business reasons
the budget is proved by the commission
and truly serves as a blueprint
for operations the senior team must
continue to have authority to adjust
expenses to keep the business running
while keeping overall ebitda cash flow
in the forefront so everything we do
every decision we made
every decision we make is always focused
on cash flow how much cash do we have
how much cash we're going to have for
our expenses how much are we going to
have for capital expenditures where do
we get bonds where do we do cap leasing
all those decisions are done daily
gun stock relies on the industry experts
and business professionals it employs
over 25 000
are discussed and presented to the
commissioner and chairman depending on
timing
turning budgetary control over to an
18-person delegation who do not actively
oversee complex
revenue driven businesses would be
devastating to gun stock
the current structure allows for
financial flexibility
that flexibility is a key component to a
successful business
delayed decision making and politically
driven agendas do not provide financial
responsibility and accountability to the
citizens of belknap county please oppose
house bill 1078
i do have here too that i will leave i
do have
copies of our financial statements that
we present on a weekly basis excuse me
on a monthly basis to the commissioners
and these are also available online and
these are also sent to the delegation so
this breaks down
all 19 departments what our cash flow is
what we've spent money on and then we
also discuss what's our plan each and
coming month of the future of the
business could you give those to
representative power and she'll pass
and catherine did you say your title was
you're the chief financial officer
correct
other questions for
the chief financial officer yes
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for
i'd uh i'd like to ask what the
rationale behind getting a capital lease
be versus uh
getting a uh a bond other than uh
uh having the bond approved by the
county convention would be
actually in business capital leases are
usually for assets that are less than
five years where bonds are usually that
exceed 10 15 and 20 years so in in
accounting
you'll usually take a cap
cap lease for a short term asset less
than five years and then we would bond
something that's 10 15 20 years
thank you representative
thank you mr chair thank you miss white
for taking my question so would you
believe that your business the
gun stock ski area
is one of the prime businesses for new
hampshire which is tourism and
entertainment is that uh outdoor would
you believe that yes i would
okay and what is your follow-up just a
quick follow-up
uh what is your you know how many uh
ski areas and what percentage of that is
a big gun stock can you repeat that i
said in new hampshire we have several
that's our crown jewel in terms of ski
areas and outdoor activities and so
would you say it's one of the top ten or
one of the top five in the state
i'd like to believe it's one of the best
yes
and next we're going to hear from and uh
apologize if i butcher the name
uh weldon bus
bus cordy west court
help me with that
buzzword
mr chair committee i'm going to make it
real brief because a lot has been said
that i wanted to cover
okay first of all i am a taxpayer of
belknap county i'm one of the ones
that's of the 3 000 signatures that were
put on the petition there to stop this
nonsense
i'm really disturbed by it and i wonder
if uh the people who are on the
delegation had ran on the platform of
taking over the finances of gun stock if
they'd be sitting here today
now unlike well let's say i'm not in the
class of rusty
or mr condition in terms of
business but i actually
was a two environmental consulting
companies in new hampshire i was chief
operations officer and chief executive
officer for over 25 years our
gross revenue was on the same level as
gun stock
number of employees about the same
we had a great board of directors that
helped us making make strategic
decisions on things
strangely we did not have an 18 member
committee that second guessed everything
we'd decided we wanted to do and i think
this is what we're getting to here
now
one of the things i want to mention that
sort of illustrates what i would
consider the naivety of the delegation
they've met made such a point of the
hundred thousand hundred thousand
dollars in bonuses
as someone testified to earlier this is
the way business operates that's how you
keep people on board that's how you
incentivize it in our business we gave
over two hundred thousand dollars a year
we had merit plans for achieving certain
profits in their business sectors and
things like that
so
i'm going to conclude by saying
please
vote on this as inexpedient to legislate
thank you very much i have copies
of a longer testimony here if you want
it thank you if you give them to
representative power on the end
she'll pass them around
next we have
welcome brian i just asked you to
please be aware of the clock that we're
trying to manage somewhat unsuccessfully
i shall mr chair and thank you very much
chairman dolan and the committee for the
opportunity to share a few words with
you today
i come before you to strongly oppose
house bill 1078 and i ask this committee
to vote this bill in expedia to
legislate
as you have done in 2018
when house bill 1702
which was probably the cousin of this
house bill
was voted out of this committee in
expedient to legislate unanimously on a
vote of 13 to zero i went back to the
house record in 2018 and i'd like to
read the blurb that your representative
wrote
for that particular house bill
and she said this bill
house bill 1702 was drafted would
jeopardize the future of gun stock and
would give the belknap county convention
authority to control gun stock's
finances
the gun stock area commission was
created
created by special legislation in 1959
the purpose of the five-member
commission is to
operate
maintain
develop
improve and promote the gun stock area
commission
gun stock provides a significant
economic boost to the belinda
county area
and is managed to the benefit of its
residents so i just want to point out
that little bit of history this bill
before you ladies and gentlemen uh quite
frankly and i want to be very very
polite
is a piece of legislation which is a
waste of your time
and it's a waste of precious
state resources in creating this house
bill
what you need to know
is that
the prime sponsor and co-sponsors of
this legislation
are a group of folks
that never
came before the gun stock area
commissioners to let them know that they
were filing legislation
and since that has occurred they have
not had the common courtesy to come
before the legislation before the gun
stock commissioners to explain what
they're doing
this is in direct
conflict
from previous legislation two years ago
when two members of the commission
and four members of the belknap
delegation sat down and cooperatively
made changes to the gun stock enabling
statute
for the benefit of the residents the
voters and the taxpayers
that is how business is done
points for you folks to consider in your
decision making
is as i mentioned before this committee
unanimously voted a
cousin bill out in 2018 in expedient the
legislation 13-0
the house record demonstrates that as
well
the gun stock area commissioners in
november of this year
voted
in opposition to this bill that's the
official position of the gun stock area
commissioners at that time i happened to
be one of the commissioners
the audit which miss white has referred
to and she is like our president general
manager um
folks that we would not want to lose
the auditing firm of
vashawn klukay and company out of
manchester a very notable audit firm
that does
many municipal and state projects
our recent order audit which is in this
past summer
was clean
there were no
observations there were no
recommendations in the senior partner
that conducted the audit
complemented the gun stock management
team
for the cooperation in the information
they were provided as one of their
better clients in in seeking
an audit review
the commission has the the books
reviewed the finances reviewed annually
so there's nothing that's uh being
hidden
and what i have found difficult to
understand is the
folks that represent
some of us on the delegation that hide
behind the word transparency
were were not transparent enough to even
allow the commissioners to participate
in the formation of this of this
proposal
um
section one or section i in the house
bill which has been referred to by
several folks before regarding a
transfer authority
it's very simple mr chairman what
happened
if
gun stock is not allowed to manage its
operation
it has to go to a legislative body and
sit down for a meeting and schedule
appointment
that will simply the day-to-day
operations of gun stock especially
during emergency repairs
the representatives
good people in nature
unfortunately have no expertise
in many cases
have not been trained in how to read a
balance sheet or a profit and loss
statement
if enacted this house bill would create
another level of bureaucracy in
government that would seriously harm the
operation for the owners which are the
taxpayers the residents and the voters
mr chairman i'll conclude with two
observations
ladies and gentlemen i would like to
point out two important recommendations
first i asked you to vote a
recommendation of inexpedient to
legislate on house bill 1078 out of
committee
as soon as your schedule permits
secondly
i would ask you to look forward to the
future
and consider proactive legislation for
gun stock mountain resort
that would legislatively
completely
separate the business operations of gun
stock mountain resort from any future
belknap county delegation
authority
or support with this approach
the voters
the residents the taxpayers would be
responsible parties for overseeing the
successful future of gun stock without
political influence that causes harm to
the known to the treasure known as
gunstock mountain resort in in just
mr chair as a a side note
having had the opportunity to serve as
as you folks in the legislature when i
was assigned to the ways and means
committee under
chairman major and vice chairman of
romney
i learned very quickly what
good legislation is
and what poor legislation is
i submit to you today
this does not fall in the category of
good legislation in the best remedy for
this committee would be to simply uh
avoid it and expedient to legislate and
uh everyone can sort of go home
well thank you for your service as a
legislator are there any questions
yes
representative power thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question you
had referenced a house bill you said two
years ago so i assume that might be
2020. do you have the house bill number
for reference uh yes it's house bill
and i can leave with you the copy of the
house record on the disposition of that
bill
up
go ahead thank you yeah i i did note
that but i thought in your testimony you
referenced a bill two years ago which i
would be 2020 am i
misunderstanding no i i think i may have
spoken too quickly the
the the bill two years ago was house
bill 1442
and in that bill
the gun stock commissioners and four of
the representatives which are different
than the representatives here today
uh sat down and cooperatively made some
changes
for the benefit of gunstock mountain
resort and for belknap county residents
thank you and could you repeat your name
i didn't get that brian gallagher
and i noticed representative gallagher
whose name is
eric happens to be uh the same name as
my son but not the same family
yeah um
i i'd just like to point out that um we
spell our last names differently his has
the h and mine doesn't so that's how you
can tell the difference difference
between them
thank you thank you for your testimony
representative tripp
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
i believe it's been uh mentioned a
couple times that there are other uh
ski areas in this state that are in the
same
in that are state-owned but uh
the bill that you're suggesting that we
uh
pursue to separate the uh
the gun stock from the the county would
it be something that's similar to what
already exists
um thank you representative tripp for
the uh for the question um it's it's an
idea to begin with
um those other ski areas possibly could
be used as a model to create some
language but
the thought here is to allow gunstock
which is a successful business operation
to be separated from
the attempted
overtaking and the attempted budget
control from the belknap county
delegation so the thought would be in a
future session that possibly a friendly
legislator would come forward and say
well let's look at the history of this
operation
let's look at who the owners are
and let's get the politics out of it
once and for all
thank you representative
thank you mr thank you mr gallagher for
taking my question so would you
believe that
working cooperatively with the
legislation and keeping the business
independent would be a win-win
that has a very good opportunity
represented to be a win-win
the the difficulty with
the
legislators trying to become part of the
business especially without the
understanding of what it takes as miss
white has as outlined is a is a recipe
for failure and it's a recipe to
to harm the business and to harm the
taxpayers and the residents of belknap
county
one
um having served as a rep representative
in your earlier days
uh would it be an opportunity to
turn this into an amendment which would
make just do that
or is the time is not the right time i i
think the latter part of his statement
is best i think it's best for this
committee
to first make a decision on this bill
and i would hope that you would
consider making it go away
and i think then it would be important
for the gun stock commissioners to spend
some time and
do a business plan to methodically come
forward with
responsible legislation say next fall
and when we enter into the new session
have a bill that they could come back
here having done research
and
show the committee the results of
another year and also
show them the work of methodically
trying to
accomplish the best for the ski resort
versus uh doing something too quickly
and making mistakes thank you very much
thank you uh former representative
gallagher i appreciate your time and
i know it's getting near the end so
i'm glad that those in the audience have
the patience
for this we have two more speakers
they're both representatives and we'll
thank you representative and please feel
free to use the uh the wipes there if
you would like to sanitize your
microphone
no problem i raised three daughters
thank you chairman dolan
and members of the committee for hearing
my testimony today
for the record my name is raymond howard
jr i represent the citizens of bill
knapp county district eight
sounds of
alton barnes state and gilmington
i'm here today and speak
to speak in favor of amending the gun
stock enabling
statute laura of 1959 chapter 399.
for the past seven years
i have been the county delegation's
representative to the
gun stock
uh area
commission gun stock has been owned and
operated by the county for the past 80
plus years
and in 1959 at the crest of the county
commissioners
the state legislature created
the enabling statute of
chapter 399.
over time things change
and like all good legislation
there needs to be amendments made to the
enabling statute to ensure its success
and
and that the objectives
are for and of the people
over its history gun stock has had some
challenging times
in 1963 chapter
44 6
was enacted to address real estate taxes
in 1990 chapter 144 was
enacted to address water extraction for
snow making as well as
amendments to the 399 statute over the
years
in 2001 a memorandum of agreement was
created between the
gun stock area commission
and the
county delegation
this was unique to gun stock and was put
in place to facilitate gun stock from
this was based on two study committee
findings and recommendations one in 1991
uh
i'm sorry by the rkg group
and the second was in 1999
by the gun stock area task force
in the moa section 3
added a requirement that gun stock
budget
and reporter financial status be
presented annually
in 2017 the moa was not renewed in
negotiations
as a result of that failure house bill
that you heard about recently
was introduced in january of 2020
and was signed into law
house bill 40
made some changes to chapter 399 that
eliminated the need for a future moa
one thing that was not addressed in 1442
was making the requirement of having an
annual budget presentation
at the same time as the annual report as
required in 399 semicolon 14
appropriations and revenues part f
during the time of the written budget
was in place under the moa
it created no issues
i believe a
presented and approved budget by the
county gun stock area commission
is essential to the transparency of good
government
and before i conclude i would like to
address a couple of statements that were
made today
um
is fire is selling or leasing if you
look in 399
semicolon 10 f
it's very specific that only that can
only happen
under
a unanimous or a majority vote of both
the county commissioners
the county delegation
and the gun stock area commissioners
and also there was uh
a mention about who owned gun stock to
begin with well
it's always been owned by gun stock i
mean by the county of belknap
and if you look in the enabling statute
of 399 semicolon 18
it's it specifies that when the
commission is created all the funds that
the county holds
will be turned over to the commission
so in conclusion i support fort
house bill
or an amended
version of the bill
that will require the gac to
present
a complete budget of expenditures
receipts
and
in the in the current fiscal year as
required in 399
semicolon 14
this is
you know this is something that i really
believe that needs to be
brought forward because
in the past where there was no oversight
gun stock ran into trouble
and it was the taxpayers that had to
foot the bill to eliminate
that default of gun stock and we don't
want to see that happening again in the
future
and the best way to keep an eye on the
prize so to speak and it is a prize we
love gun stock there's no no one that
really wants to sell or well we can't
sell it two study committees has shown
that but we don't want to lease it we
just want to know
what is their budget what are they
planning on doing with all this money
that they take in in revenues
and i don't think it's an unreasonable
request
so i thank you and i'll answer any
questions thank you representative
representative you had a question uh two
actually uh thank you i will ask for
permission before the second one though
um my first question to you is you
referenced some
um 399 um colon 10 f and i didn't have a
chance to kind of look it up but you
said that it can only be sold with the
majority of those two bodies is it a
simple majority or is it a super
majority uh i believe it's
two out of the three commissioners the
county commissioners
uh four out of the five
gun stock commissioners
and two-thirds of the county delegation
okay so it looks like a super majority
thank you yes and may i ask a second
thank you
um
they've they've been talking about um
the default that gunstock did for
whatever the reasons why i'm not going
to judge anybody but that that was 20
years ago why are we waiting to now to
um
to suddenly decide that we need to kind
of take control and make sure i mean
haven't they over the 20 years kind of
shown that they are doing the right
thing well it was 20 years ago
under the recommendation of the study
committees
that
the county
bail gun stock out by assuming
about six and a half million dollars
worth of their debt
uh the committee also recommended that
gun stock repay those loans over time
when they could
and also in that original moa was the
requirement that gun stock came before
the
delegation
to show
what they were doing you know present a
budget
and they've done that up until the last
couple of years ago 2017
i think they still presented it even
though we didn't have the moa in place
but the last couple of years we've just
seen no budget
and uh one of the things i was
um sort of accused of is
when the
bonuses were brought up in a
conversation
we
you know
we've always
let the commissioners reward the
employees with some kind of compensation
they've always had some kind of revenue
sharing in place
uh not being told what these bonuses
were going to be
uh
so you know we didn't realize that they
were planning on spending you know a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars to
bonus
uh you know half a dozen employees
so that was kind of a
you know how do you address
something that's normally done but not
to that extent
without knowing
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative
majpudi
thank you mr chair thank you mr uh thank
you representative for taking my
question
if um
until 2017
until 2017. things were fine and
have the gun stock area
repaid the bond and
have they paid the taxes to the
taxpayers that they
have contributed until 2017
yes yearly payments have been made for
the
the moa was renewed every five years and
every
time it was renegotiated the payment
schedule changed a little bit but and
about three and a half million dollars
of the original six and a half was
repaid
and so the legislation that was put in
in 2020
um house bill 1442
was to eliminate the
the process of doing an moa every five
years
and because every five years you can
have a totally different delegation make
up
totally different
uh commission makeup this was to put
something in legislation that would
over time eventually pay off those
uh bonds that were absorbed by the
county taxpayers and then at some point
in time when those are paid often it
will actually be revenue to the county
uh but right now we're still we're still
looking at probably two and a half
to three million dollars in bond debt
that's never been repaid
one last follow-up okay yeah um
just the last two years you referred to
i know there were no payments made no
last two years when we look back would
you believe that we were in a pandemic
year nobody knew what was going on or
is that something that
we are in as legislators we had no idea
what was how we were dealing with that
so is that a consideration at all or
having done something really good in the
middle of a pandemic wasn't that
something that we have to reward our
businesses yes and i think all the
employees of gun stock should be
rewarded
my
my question
rebuttal question that would be well we
still put together a state budget even
though we're in a
you know uh interesting situation with
cohort
uh and we've heard testimony today that
refers to their budget
themselves they've talked about their
budget and staying in budget or
exceeding budget you know all the
delegation is asking for here is to be
able to look at your budget let's
show us your budget so we know what
you're doing
you know that's transparency in
government and this is a government
entity i know it's running like a
business but it's still
owned by the taxpayers and it's a
representative
wrong
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
so with your testimony
gun stock's been
owned by the county for over 80 years
and operated as a ski resort
yes originally it was basically just a
skier
how would you consider is it responsibly
managed compared to comparable ski areas
in the state
uh right now it's being well managed yes
you know i have no we have no problem
with the management all we want is to
see a budget
you know just like any other department
you know we could we could tell the show
if yeah go ahead you know do whatever
you want we don't care to see your
budget that wouldn't be responsible to
the taxpayers
follow-up mr chairman thank you
so
after hearing the testimony today do you
do you think it should operate as the
sheriff's department or should it have
special considerations because of the
business nature and the industry
um operations that we see in that type
of industry yes
the enabling statute 399 is the document
that gives them their special
powers
uh it's it's
you know it's all listed in here
um under the statute
and it works well occasionally you know
it needs to be looked at and maybe
something needs to be tweaked and i
think right now this is something that
two study committees found in the 90s
when gun stock was actually getting
further behind in their debt plus they
were coming to the
from the taxpayers to keep it
functioning
and at that time both study committees
recommended that
gunstock produce an annual budget
to the delegation
and they've done that since up until the
last couple of years
follow up just one more thank you mr
chairman
um representative
we heard testimony today that there is a
communication i mean the commissioners
are
appointed by the delegation correct
correct and they do present a budget
and they share their financial
information with the delegation is that
true
no they what they
what they give us annually is a audit of
okay
okay we want we want to see a projected
budget for
the current year
okay and like i said they've done that
in the past for the last you know since
the moa's enactment in 2001.
and uh
but they you know that practice stopped
when uh
a couple of years ago when the moa
one more i promise it'll be the last one
i'm reading the bill right now and
i think just presenting a budget as what
you're you're hoping occurs
is is not just what this bill is about
um and i just want to point out section
h and i
thank you
um
yeah so you know the the proposed
legislative change right now is
uh probably a little more extreme
than
some
members of the delegation feel is
necessary
but i'm supporting it
because i know
how the legislative process works and
how we can amend it to make it work for
all parties involved
thank you i uh before we go to our last
representative
thank you for indulging me on chairman
and um i just again have two quick
questions i'm sorry i keep playing um
trying to look at you through another
representative um
the
i when i'm looking at the um
the statements of net position i look at
2021 i see the 247 404 paid i assume
that was to the um
to the county and then i see in 2020
that there was nothing nothing paid in
the previous years 2019 2018 2017 where
we don't have those numbers was there
anything paid no there wasn't so just
2021 you're saying is that correct yes
yes and 17 was the last year
a payment was made under the
we did a like a continuing resolution on
the moa for one year
to try to hammer out the differences
between the delegation and the
commission
and uh
you know we finally come up with the a
compromise and a way forward on the
may i just clarify that one question i
just
so i i do see though in 2020 there was a
payment of 247
right okay i may i ask this
that was under the new
the amendments made to the enabling
statute got it thank you um and i just
want to make sure that i did understand
that um you never see a current year's
budget is that what you're you're saying
there we haven't seen a but we haven't
had a budget presenters to us for a
couple of years now no
okay thank you
thank you representative appreciate it
very much right and our next next and
presenter will be representative lang
and while he's coming up
let me say that i understand
how uh how long you've all been here and
how emotional
in some cases these issues can be and
let me compliment you all on being very
professional
and
very understanding for the various
points of view you've been listening to
so with that i'll introduce
representative lang for the final
comments
thank you mr chairman i am
representative tim lang i represent
belknap four the towns of tilton and
samerton
i am the chairman of the house fish and
game committee
i'm in my third term
in belknap county i actually replaced
brian when he didn't run i took his seat
[Music]
so
yeah welcome to the craziness of belknap
county
um
you know this is the first time i think
i'm ever heard of legislation because a
chartering organization is doing too
good we want to penalize them and take
away their budgeting powers because we
don't want that so great
i think representative manjapudi had a
nail on the head earlier when she was
talking about the exercise of oversight
is done through the process of
appointment and the in the process of
removal which the belt up delegation has
full authority
if you're wondering why we're here one
of the things you'll also know is that
belknap county is in the middle of i
don't know i think at this point we've
had four commissioners that we've had
allegations against that that people
wanted to remove and not remove and the
delegation can't make up its mind
and on top of that we also have the
commissioners the county commissioners
and the belknap county delegation
fighting in a lawsuit as well so kind of
give you the nature of the belknap
county delegation and its relationship
with other entities within our county
so when we talk about belham county and
it was a lot talked about covid and what
happened in the last two years i served
on the governor's reopening task force
um i did that uh for
a year and a half 72 meetings i don't
know how many uh guidances i drafted and
amended through that process as one of
the chief members on the on the
reopening task force including the ski
rules um the hospitality rules food and
beverage we all know about how bad our
businesses were hit hard in the food and
beverage areas but and that that was a
direct relationship to gun stock in
addition to that we had the outdoor
attractions guidance which again limited
and restricted what was going on in that
in in gun stock so if you don't know gun
stocks not just skiing uh at gun stock
i've skeed i've segwayed i've ziplined
i've swam camped hiked
there's a lot four seasons since i've
been around in belknap county in four
decades i've raised four kids all of
which have learned to ski and on other
things it was our family activity we
went camping there we went ziplining
there
so again a lot they've done a lot to
turn this into a four-season destination
and the management's been great
um you know
how were there rough times back 20 years
ago sure but i'm pretty sure that was an
economic hardship for everybody and not
just gun stock by itself and because of
its decisions we all know that uh going
back
around 2000 there were some issues
um the member the dot com bubble burst
right and everybody was in financial
trouble for a long time a lot of
businesses failed
so
i guess what i'm going to say the one
word you heard representative silver say
over and over and over again
control that's what this is about
maintaining control
they want to know what's going they want
to know i will tell you that in my
relationship my three terms with gun
stock
anytime i picked up the phone and called
and asked for information it was given
to me within one or two days didn't
matter what it was
somebody was on the phone with me and
and presenting it to me or emailing to
me and getting it the information's
there the financials are online you can
go to the gun stock area commissioner's
website and all the budgeting all the
minute meetings are there all the
budgeting stuff is there so it's
available for anybody
um so
as you can tell i don't like this bill
i'd like to see it killed
i think that you're stepping into a
squabble family squabble that's going on
right now that needs to be resolved
within the family
and not through legislation this is
using the sledgehammer to fix the
problem and i'd urge you to vote itl
thank you representative
for those of you that are still here
regarding gun stock just so you
understand
today was the public hearing
and we have to now take it through an
executive session
the executive session is is when we will
individually vote on whether we support
or reject the bill that's before us
uh
cal i i urge you to review the house
calendar
because it's not published yet when that
executive session is going to be held
but i would
i would believe we're talking about
somewhere around
the end of the week of february 7th
so if you're if you're curious and want
to be here you can't input to the
executive session but you can certainly
observe
and make notes but somewhere around the
week of february 7th is when we will
execute this bill but
the exact date will be published in the
house calendar
which should come out
later this week for that that time frame
so uh yes you have a question sir
yes um
[Music]
no
you can
[Music]
submit an amendment
to the
legislation that's before us if you want
you're welcome to send any one of us or
memos or or emails
if you want to clarify something
personally but there won't be an
official opportunity to
thank you
mr chair one more thing i apologize
before i'll take any questions is that
i'm happy to work if you i tell this
bill i'm back next session
next term i'll be happy to work with the
gun stock area commissioners to develop
the language for a bill to do that
separation we were talking about
thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative lang for taking my
question
um
can you just uh
restate or
what is your relationship with the gun
the gun stock you are one of the
commissioners or so i'm a state
representative the chair of fish and
game and i'm on the county delegation so
i see what they come forward with and
what goes on
again as part of the county delegation
answering or
answering questions from my constituents
this has been a huge topic of belknap
county you go pick up the laconia daily
sun you can't miss a day without
something being said about what's going
on right now between the delegation and
gun stock so again i
i regularly have to answer my
constituents responses on what's going
on they've got a question i don't know
the answer i give gun stock a call say
can you give me the answer to this
someone gets back to me gives me the
answer i'll be able to respond to my
constituents so again they've been
extremely responsive to me as a rep
state representative and a member of the
delegation trying to get answers for our
constituents in belknap county
a follow-up mr chair yes so what you are
answering to your constituency the
voters so
uh voters of belknap county
that's correct
this morning let me finish my question
so uh in that capacity
what i you know we see in a large number
of opposition on online so what you're
hearing from your constituency is
exactly opposite of what this bill wants
to do am i correct absolutely vast
majority of the citizens that have
reached out to me oppose this bill if
you look online i checked before i came
down committee on the online vote online
you know opposition support it's five to
two hundred and thirty something never
mind the twelve hundred
uh signatures the the chairman got uh by
a vast majority in our community are
opposed to this bill thank you
okay and we had one more comment with
this this is very unusual for us to be
taking
i i would rather you send in
some written clarification i think that
would be more appropriate otherwise
we're going to have to give
that same opportunity to do others on
the
in the audience
okay uh
thank you all very much for being here
we are going to take a break
and then
we're going to take up an executive
session
on
1665 right thank you we're going to take
that up for the executive session but uh
please take five minutes and
oh
okay
you
right
everybody
just mr chair
yes
if you can just highlight what the
amendment does to
we had a bunch of questions at the
hearing and what she has done
is
answer
the questions that we had when we heard
the bill
and made changes
some of them had to do with
what you could use the money for
and oh we reduced in line 26 a
municipality may only draw from the
municipal road and brief bridge disaster
relief fund if the amount of the total
damage is at least 50 and it was a
hundred percent originally which we
thought was too high
um i think the administration
[Music]
has been altered
but primarily it was that question about
how much of the damage should it be
um is one of the
oh and the municipalities wishing to
draw from this fund in the future this
was a drafting error
municipalities wishing to draw from this
fund in the future shall pay into the
fund annually in an amount equal to one
half of one percent of its municipal
operating budget and that was a drafting
error earlier i think it was like one
hundredth of one percent before clearly
wrong
um that's the parts that i remember
having been corrected
right this is uh an amendment put forth
by representative aaron and
she has seen this and concurs with it
yes
you might have said this iv2 but i think
one of the other important things is uh
line one on page two an assessment
report be prepared by professional
engineer and it's in the other one in
the original bill it specified i forgot
exactly what it's
a certified road engineer and this just
makes it which is a thing that i think
mostly doesn't exist yeah so we were we
were giving a title as something that uh
didn't didn't exist yet
or maybe it was something that someone
okay so we have a motion on the
amendment
in a second
thank you for clarifying those
mr clerk would you like to take the role
okay and jim you have a
your mic on
yeah all right
okay remember to uh house bill 1665
uh vice chairman pmrt yes clerk votes
yes representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas
yes
representative mcbride
representative melvin
representative
uh representative power
yes
thank you uh representative
representative stavis is not here
uh representative megaputi
yes
representative vann
representative gallagher
yes
representative ryan
and chairman dawn yes
uh passes uh 15 to zero okay so now we
have
an approved amendment so looking now for
a motion to
otp as amended
i make a motion uh otp uh
second
motion has been made and second as
amended yes
is there any yes seconded by uh
representative ayer
do we have any further discussion on the
motion as amended
yes i i just wanted to say this is a
true
parliamentary and democratic
way of exec and i really appreciate that
and that was my eagerness to say
seeing no further uh comments i'll ask
the clerk to take a roll
okay uh hb 1665 as amended
vice chairman pmrt yeah
click votes yes
representative tripp i vote yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas
yes
uh representative mcbride
uh representative melvin
representative
representative power yes
gilman yes
representative
yes
uh representative megaputi
representative fan
representative clee yes
representative gallagher
yes
representative ryan
and chairman dolan yeah
now i
i will um
attempt to put this on the consent
calendar but because it has a financial
uh note on it i may not be able to do
that so uh
we'll see what happens i i there's some
a little confusion about that
but uh
i think it's unlikely that we get it on
the consent calendar but it'll appear in
the
in the regular calendar if not on a
okay that ends the
thank you all very much for staying late
it's been a
been a long a long day now we have two
more sessions this week thursday and
friday
and i don't intend
i told you
today i didn't intend to have an
executive session but i don't intend to
have any executive sessions thursday or
friday but we have set we do have
hearings thursday and friday
so if you
i want you to be safe if you
look out the window and find a driving
snowstorm on friday morning i ask you to
use your own judgment whether or not you
can safely
make it to the state house but
the only requirement we'll have is we
need to have a quorum
in order to conduct business
but
you don't have to worry about executive
session absenteeism because we're not
okay
keep your fingers crossed for good
weather
you